New York City, the Port Authority Bus Terminal, a very cold night, a few weeks ago--
几周前，纽约市，港务局巴士总站，一个非常寒冷的夜晚——
Yeah, explain what time it is, and where we are and what we're doing.
嗯，解释一下现在是什么时间，我们在哪里，我们在做什么。
It is 11:14 PM. And we are waiting for a Texas bus.
现在是晚上11点14分。我们正在等一辆来自得克萨斯州的巴士。
Texas bus with who inside?
得州巴士，里面有谁？
So we don't know the number yet, but we have asylum seekers that are there that just come from the border.
我们还不知道具体人数，但里面有一些刚从边境过来的寻求庇护者。
This is one of the buses that Governor Greg Abbott sent to New York City, starting in the summer of last year. You probably heard about this. Hoping to make a point about what Texas is dealing with, he sent migrants on buses to cities run by Democrats-- Washington, DC, Los Angeles, Chicago, Philadelphia, Denver, and New York.
这是格雷格·阿博特州长从去年夏天开始发往纽约市的巴士之一。你可能听说过这件事。为了表达对得州所面临困境的看法，他把移民用巴士送往由民主党人管理的城市——华盛顿特区、洛杉矶、芝加哥、费城、丹佛和纽约。
Over 27,000 people have arrived at this spot this way, where many of them have been greeted by a 5'2" Black woman, named Adama Bah.
通过这种方式，已经有超过27,000人到达了这个地点，其中许多人受到了一位名叫阿达玛·巴的5英尺2英寸高的黑人女性的迎接。
How many nights a week do you do this?
你每周做这个多少个晚上？
Mm. I don't keep count anymore. [LAUGHS]
嗯。我已经不再统计了。（笑）
But what's the most it gets? Like, what's a hard week for you?
但是最多的时候呢？对你来说，辛苦的一周是什么样？
A hard week is every day, a bus. I put the kids to sleep, and then I ran over here. I'm a mommy. And I'll make it back in time, where they won't notice I'm gone.
辛苦的一周就是每天都有巴士。我哄孩子们睡觉，然后跑过来。我是一位妈妈。我会及时赶回去，让他们察觉不到我离开过。
Do they know you left?
他们知道你离开了吗？
No.
不知道。
Thing is, Adama doesn't work for the city of New York. She runs a community center for newly arrived immigrants, called Afrikana. She's been doing this work with migrants for 18 years-- for a long time, just out of her car, though she still does a lot of work from her car, going around a city to where recent migrants are, talking to them in the car.
问题是，阿达玛并不为纽约市政府工作。她经营着一家名为“Afrikana”的社区中心，专门帮助新抵达的移民。她从事这项移民工作已经18年了——很长一段时间里，她只是在自己的车里工作，尽管现在她仍然在车里处理很多工作，在城市里四处奔走，去移民们所在的地方，在车里与他们交谈。
My car has been my office for years, and it's still my office.
我的车多年来一直是我的办公室，现在仍然是。
And are there certain things you always are sure that you keep in the car?
有没有什么东西是你一定会确保放在车里的？
I have so many stuff. So organizer 101 is always have a portable charger, paper and pen. I have toothbrush, toothpaste-- peppermint, because I'm always talking to people. I don't think-- I don't want to be known as the lady with the bad breath.
我有太多东西了。组织者入门指南第一条就是永远带着移动电源、纸和笔。我有牙刷、牙膏——薄荷味的，因为我一直在和人说话。我不认为……我不希望被称为那个口臭的女士。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
She can help you, but she has a bad breath. I have deodorant, emergency change of clothes. Because sometimes-- it's not on purpose, but I spend overnight.
她能帮你，但她有口臭。我有除臭剂、应急换洗的衣服。因为有时——不是故意的，但我会在这里过夜。
Have you had to sleep overnight here, waiting for buses?
你不得不在这里通宵等待巴士吗？
Yeah, I have. I have pillows. I have a blanket.
是的，我经历过。我有枕头。我有毯子。
When the very first bus arrived from Texas in August 2022, it was migrant aid groups like Adama's who got advance word that it was coming and greeted the bus-- not the city. But soon enough, the city government got on board. Mayor Eric Adams showed up at the Port Authority to greet one of the buses, ready to prove that New York City is a city of immigrants that loves and welcomes immigrants.
2022年8月第一辆来自得州的巴士抵达时，是像阿达玛这样的移民援助组织提前得到了消息并迎接了巴士——而不是市政府。但很快，市政府也参与了进来。埃里克·亚当斯市长出现在港务局迎接其中一辆巴士，准备证明纽约市是一个热爱并欢迎移民的移民城市。
I have to provide services for families that are here, and that's what we're going to do, and that's what our responsibility as a city-- I'm proud that this is a right-to-shelter state.
我必须为这里的家庭提供服务，这就是我们要做的，也是我们作为城市的责任——我为这是一个拥有“避难权”的州而感到自豪。
Right to shelter-- that means that New York City had to provide temporary housing to anyone who needs it. And the city took that seriously.
避难权——这意味着纽约市必须为任何需要它的人提供临时住所。市政府认真对待了这一点。
They started to show up. They set up operations.
他们开始出现。他们建立了运作机制。
And where did the city do its operation? What was it?
市政府是在哪里开展行动的？是什么样的行动？
Inside there in Port Authority.
就在港务局里面。
Right through those doors here?
就穿过这里的那些门？
Right through those doors.
就穿过那些门。
On that spot, the city would take people's names and information, and then send them on to shelters. Groups like Adama's would hand out food, clothing, toiletries. As word got out that New York City would house everyone who showed up, more and more people started arriving.
在那儿，市政府会记录人们的名字和信息，然后把他们送到避难所。像阿达玛这样的团体则会分发食物、衣物和洗漱用品。随着“纽约市将安置所有出现的人”这一消息传开，越来越多的人开始抵达。
Today, the 27,000 people that Governor Abbott sent are just a tiny portion of the 150,000 who've shown up on buses, trains, cars, and planes since the spring of 2022. New York City was not set up to help this many people this way. The right to shelter was created for homeless men in the Bowery, not for thousands of new arrivals each week.
今天，阿博特州长送来的27,000人，仅仅是自2022年春天以来乘坐巴士、火车、汽车和飞机抵达的15万人中的一小部分。纽约市并没有准备好以这种方式帮助这么多人。避难权最初是为鲍厄里区的无家可归男性制定的，而不是为了每周数千名新抵达者。
By this fall, it was costing the city $10 million a night, and the mayor completely changed his tune. Yes, New York loves immigrants, but not this many this fast, needing assistance. And the mayor became a kind of one-man unwelcome wagon, flying to Ecuador and Colombia and Mexico to hold press conferences saying, don't come to New York, declaring a state of emergency in the city, begging the federal government for help, which did not arrive.
到了今年秋天，这让城市每晚耗资1000万美元，市长的口吻彻底变了。是的，纽约热爱移民，但不是这么多、这么快、需要援助的移民。市长变成了一种“不受欢迎的传令官”，飞往厄瓜多尔、哥伦比亚和墨西哥召开新闻发布会，说“不要来纽约”，宣布城市进入紧急状态，乞求联邦政府援助，但援助并没有到来。
By October of this year, the city had spent over $2 billion and opened over 200 emergency shelters. It had cut the amount of time that immigrants could stay in a shelter from as long as they needed to 60 days for families and 30 days for individuals. And finally, in October, New York went to court to change the law and suspend the right to shelter for the city. Mayor Adams started saying that migrants will be sleeping on the streets. It's not a question of if, but when.
截至今年10月，市政府已经花费了超过20亿美元，并开设了200多个紧急避难所。它将移民在避难所停留的时间从“根据需要”缩短为家庭60天，个人30天。最终，在10月，纽约诉诸法庭以修改法律并暂停该市的避难权。亚当斯市长开始说，移民将睡在街头。这不再是“是否会发生”的问题，而是“何时发生”的问题。
We're getting 10,000 migrants a month.
我们每个月有1万名移民涌入。
This is Mayor Adams this fall.
这是亚当斯市长今年秋天的言论。
This issue will destroy New York City, destroy New York City. Every community in this city is going to be impacted. We have a $12 billion deficit that we're going to have to cut. Every service in this city is going to be impacted, all of us.
这个问题会摧毁纽约市，摧毁纽约市。这个城市的每个社区都将受到影响。我们有120亿美元的赤字需要削减。这个城市的每一项服务都将受到影响，我们所有人都会。
Or maybe it's not quite that bad. The city's chief fiscal officer, the comptroller, says the mayor is overblowing the effects of the migrants on the city's budget. And one political question in New York is whether the mayor is now scapegoating the migrants to push through budget cuts he'd hoped to do anyway. Though it is true that money is tight, one day, Adama says, city personnel just didn't show up at Port Authority anymore to greet immigrants.
或者情况可能没那么糟。该市的首席财务官（审计长）表示，市长夸大了移民对城市预算的影响。纽约的一个政治问题是，市长现在是否在利用移民作为替罪羊，以推行他本来就想实施的预算削减。虽然资金确实紧张，但有一天，阿达玛说，市政府的工作人员不再出现在港务局迎接移民了。
They just stopped. They didn't tell us that they were stopping. They-- the same day, they just told us they were closing operations. They didn't give us a reason. They didn't give us-- they didn't work with us. They didn't give us a heads-up. They just shut it down.
他们只是停了。他们没告诉我们他们要停。他们在同一天告诉我们他们要关闭行动。他们没给我们理由。他们没和我们合作。他们没给我们任何预警。他们直接关掉了。
Which brings us to why Adama's here, where her kids are with her parents at home, sleeping. If she weren't here, this bus that's arriving from Texas would drop off a few dozen people in this alley between 41st and 42nd Street. A couple National Guardsmen would sleepily emerge from the car they're sitting in across the street and hand out an address to go to and a map. And they'd have to make their way there on their own.
这就是阿达玛为什么在这里，而她的孩子和她父母在家睡觉的原因。如果她不在这里，这辆从得州来的巴士会把几十个人扔在第41街和第42街之间的这条小巷里。几个国民警卫队队员会睡眼惺忪地从街对面的车里钻出来，递给他们一个地址和一张地图。他们就得自己想办法去那里。
The address is for the Roosevelt Hotel, which the city has set up as the intake center for migrants arriving in New York. 20-minute walk from here, right through the center of Times Square.
那个地址是罗斯福酒店，市政府把它设为抵达纽约移民的接收中心。离这儿步行20分钟，穿过时代广场中心。
So we're here to welcome them, and then actually safely send them there.
所以我们在这里迎接他们，然后安全地送他们去那里。
Adama's organization partnered with another organization to hire a bus.
阿达玛的组织与另一个组织合作租了一辆巴士。
So what I'm going to do is put them in the bus and send them straight to the Roosevelt, and tell them, please give them food right now. And then, they will give them sandwiches and water. Yeah.
所以我打算把他们放进巴士，直接送到罗斯福酒店，告诉他们，请现在给他们食物。然后，他们会给他们三明治和水。是的。
The other thing she's going to do is get on the bus and give them a little speech. The bus driver will translate to Spanish. The speech is partly practical. She gives out a phone number they type in their cell phones for somebody they can call once they're in a shelter, to direct them to the services they need.
她要做的另一件事是上车给他们做个简短的演讲。巴士司机负责翻译成西班牙语。演讲部分是实用的。她分发一个电话号码，让他们输入手机，这样他们进入避难所后可以联系某人，引导他们获得所需的服务。
But also, she's doing this herself, the head of the organization in the middle of the night, bus after bus, because she thinks it's important that somebody says "welcome," just in some basic human way, to people who have come so far, full of worry and fear and hope.
但她这样做，作为组织负责人，在半夜里，一辆又一辆巴士地接送，是因为她认为对那些满怀担忧、恐惧和希望、走了那么远的人来说，有人能说声“欢迎”在基本的人文层面是非常重要的。
So as a former asylum seeker, I didn't get that welcome party. My parents didn't get that welcome party. So I am doing it for them.
作为曾经的寻求庇护者，我没得到那样的欢迎仪式。我的父母也没得到。所以我为他们这样做。
But the thing you say is-- just so I understand, so the thing you're going to say is what? Give me the speech.
但你刚才说——我想确认一下，你要说的是什么？告诉我你的演讲内容。
So the first step is "Bienvenidos a Nueva York. You are in New York City, in Manhattan, in Port Authority. We want to welcome you. We're going to count you, and we're going to put you in another bus and transport you to Roosevelt Hotel, where there's a bathroom, there's water, there's food, and there's Wi-Fi." The Wi-Fi always gets them.
第一步是“欢迎来到纽约。你们在纽约市，在曼哈顿，在港务局。我们想欢迎你们。我们会登记你们的人数，然后送你们上另一辆巴士，把你们运送到罗斯福酒店，那里有浴室、有水、有食物，还有Wi-Fi。”Wi-Fi总是能吸引他们。
She tells them that her organization can help with clothing and legal aid and anything else they need help with.
她告诉他们，她的组织可以帮助他们获取衣物、法律援助以及他们需要的任何其他帮助。
And then we tell them, listen, this is a country of immigrants. I am an immigrant. I am from Africa. I am from Guinea. I'm an immigrant just like you.
然后我们告诉他们，听着，这是一个移民国家。我是个移民。我来自非洲。我来自几内亚。我和你们一样是移民。
I made it, and you will make it. It's not easy in the beginning, but it will get better. You're welcome here. No matter what anybody tells you, you have rights. Practice those rights. If you don't know what they are, we will tell you what they are. And then, we let them out.
我成功了，你们也会成功的。开始并不容易，但情况会好起来的。你们在这里是受欢迎的。不管别人怎么说，你们拥有权利。行使这些权利。如果你们不知道是什么，我们会告诉你们。然后，我们就让他们离开。
OK, time check-- what time is it?
好，核对一下时间——现在几点了？
11:50. It should be pulling up. Do you want a peppermint? No?
11点50分。应该快到了。你要薄荷糖吗？不要？
Yeah, yeah.
要，要。
Oh. Here you go.
哦。给你。
Thanks.
谢谢。
We've been standing in the cold for over an hour. Random people walk up to Adama to start conversations or ask for directions. She just seems like the kind of person you can do that with. At around quarter past midnight, she reveals something that I can't believe I'm learning after standing there so long together.
我们在寒风中站了一个多小时。不时有人走到阿达玛身边开始交谈或问路。她看起来就是那种你可以随意交谈的人。午夜1点15分左右，她透露了一件事，一起站了这么久，我简直不敢相信。
I have my pajamas on. [LAUGHS]
我穿着睡衣。（笑）
(LAUGHING) What?
（笑）什么？
This is my pajamas.
这是我的睡衣。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
I am.
我是认真的。
Oh, my god. It's true. Those are checked, teal-and-navy pajamas.
天哪。是真的。那是格纹、蓝绿色和深蓝色的睡衣。
I know. And I was like, ah, I don't feel like dressing up.
我知道。我当时想，啊，我不想打扮。
OK, so you're wearing a maroon coat and teal-and-navy pajamas, dark-blue hijab, backpack--
好，所以你穿着一件栗色外套，穿着蓝绿色和深蓝色的睡衣，深蓝色头巾，背包——
I'm ready to walk the runway. [LAUGHS]
我准备好走秀了。（笑）
Exactly.
确实。
Finally, more than an hour after that, 1:30 in the morning, the bus from Texas rolls up.
终于，一个多小时后，凌晨1点30分，得州来的巴士开过来了。
OK. You cannot go inside, so you just have to wait here.
好了。你们不能进去，所以就在这里等。
The bus door opens. She climbs the steps and stands at the front of the bus and makes her speech, which does the job. When everybody emerges from the bus after their three-day ride, they are not the exhausted, huddled masses that I expected they'd be. People are beaming, excited.
巴士门开了。她爬上台阶，站在车头做了演讲，这很有效。当所有人在经过三天的旅程后走下巴士时，他们并不是我预想中筋疲力尽、挤作一团的群体。人们眉飞色舞，非常兴奋。
Hola, bienvenidas. Fila por favor.
你好，欢迎。请排队。
Some carry suitcases. Some carry plastic garbage bags filled with their stuff. In my terrible high-school Spanish, I ask where they're from. And families look so happy when they answer.
有些人提着手提箱。有些人提着装满东西的塑料垃圾袋。用我糟糕的高中西班牙语，我问他们从哪来。当他们回答时，家庭看起来很高兴。
De donde viene?
你从哪里来？
Venezuela.
委内瑞拉。
Venezuela? De donde viene?
委内瑞拉？你从哪里来？
Honduras.
洪都拉斯。
Colombia.
哥伦比亚。
Y de donde?
你呢？
Colombia.
哥伦比亚。
Colombia?
哥伦比亚？
Venezuela.
委内瑞拉。
They tell me they've been traveling for a month and a half, two months, three months. It's a dangerous trip for many of them through the Darien Gap. Most are from Venezuela, a lot of Colombia. Plus, one family where the dad proudly shouted his answer like, I don't know about these people, but I definitely belong here.
他们告诉我，他们已经旅行了一个半月、两个月、三个月。对他们中的许多人来说，穿越达里恩峡谷是一次危险的旅程。大多数来自委内瑞拉，很多来自哥伦比亚。此外，有一个家庭，父亲自豪地大喊出他的答案，好像在说，我不知道这些人怎么样，但我绝对属于这里。
De donde?
从哪来？
De Mexico! Viva Mexico!
从墨西哥！墨西哥万岁！
That guy has family in New York, who are on their way to come pick him up. Most everybody else got into the other bus Adama arranged and headed over to the migrant welcome center at the Roosevelt Hotel, a once-glamorous 1,000-room behemoth that fills a block of 45th Street, a place where, back in the day, you might spot JFK or Eisenhower or Guy Lombardo, that is now the city's new Ellis Island, the entrance point.
那个家伙在纽约有亲戚，正赶来接他。其他人大多上了阿达玛安排的另一辆巴士，前往罗斯福酒店的移民接待中心。那曾是一座辉煌的、拥有1000个房间的庞然大物，占据了第45街的一个街区。过去，你可能会在那里看到肯尼迪、艾森豪威尔或盖·伦巴多，现在它是这座城市新的埃利斯岛，入口点。
Salida por favor.
请从出口走。
Adama guides everyone off the bus into the lobby.
阿达玛引导每个人下车进入大堂。
Hola. Entra. Entra por favor. Familia?
你好。进来。进来。家人？
How much Spanish do you speak now?
你现在会说多少西班牙语？
None. [LAUGHS]
一点也不会。（笑）
The welcome center at the Roosevelt Hotel is one part of the city's response. It's pretty well run. They have legal services to help you apply for asylum. There are free diapers and warm food.
罗斯福酒店的欢迎中心是城市应对措施的一部分。它运作得相当好。他们有法律服务来帮助你申请庇护。有免费的尿布和热食。
They'll replace your meds. The city started doing this when a kid showed up whose meds for epilepsy had been seized by border patrol. And from here, they'll send you to one of the over 200 shelters around the city, which are mostly not as nice as this.
他们会更换你的药物。市政府在一名孩子出现后开始这样做，那孩子的癫痫药物被边境巡逻队没收了。从这里，他们会把你送到城市里200多个避难所中的一个，大部分环境不如这里。
Some are in school gymnasiums, office buildings. If you have family elsewhere in the country, there's a desk here where New York City will happily buy you a plane ticket to go live with them and not be New York's problem anymore. 1/4 of the arrivals take that option.
有些在学校体育馆、办公楼里。如果你在全国其他地方有家人，这里有一个柜台，纽约市很乐意为你购买一张机票让你去和他们一起住，不再成为纽约的问题。1/4的抵达者采取了这种选择。
As this year ends, New York City is entering some new phase with this massive experiment at welcoming and providing services for so many new arrivals. It's put some 20,000 kids into schools. It's housing right now 60,000 migrants.
随着今年结束，纽约市进入了一个新阶段，这是一场关于接待和为如此多新抵达者提供服务的大规模实验。它已经让2万名儿童进入学校。目前安置了6万名移民。
Though in lots of ways, it has not gone so well, it hasn't put newcomers on a path to jobs and places to live. But has any American city ever done this much for new arrivals on this scale? Mayor Adams has pointed out some cities do nothing. Texas, Governor Abbott, does nothing.
尽管在很多方面，情况并不尽如人意，没有让新来者走上就业和居住的道路。但是有哪座美国城市曾经为如此规模的新来者做过这么多事吗？亚当斯市长指出，有些城市什么都不做。得州，阿博特州长，什么都不做。
I was on the border in El Paso! I saw what happened with people and children and families sleeping in airports, sleeping on the street! So don't critique what we've done! Don't tell us how we could have done it better!
我曾在埃尔帕索的边境！我看到了人们、孩子和家庭睡在机场、睡在街上！所以不要批评我们所做的一切！不要告诉我们我们本可以做得更好！
Our hearts are big, but our resources are not endless. The way goes New York goes America. And if we don't get it right in New York City, we're not going to get it right in America.
我们的心很大，但我们的资源不是无限的。纽约的走向就是美国的走向。如果我们不能在纽约市做好，我们就无法在美国做好。
Today on our show, we look at a city desperately trying to prove that it can be the sanctuary city it thinks it is. We look at the messy, flawed, generous, impossible, vast New York migrant experiment, how it's going, where it works, and where it fails so badly that people have accused New York of deliberately doing horribly so immigrants decide not to stay in the city, what it's like to arrive here and make your way right now in New York. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们审视一个绝望地试图证明自己可以成为心目中那个避难所城市的城市。我们审视混乱、有缺陷、慷慨、不可能、广阔的纽约移民实验，它进展如何，哪里有效，哪里失败得如此彻底，以至于人们指责纽约故意做得糟糕，让移民决定不留在城市；审视此刻抵达这里并努力前行的感受。来自芝加哥WBEZ，这是《美国生活》。请继续收听。
Act 1, No Sleep Till Brooklyn. So let's start with what's probably the most difficult thing New York City has faced with these new migrants-- figuring out where to house them. It's hard to find appropriate spaces. And some neighborhoods really don't want them.
第一幕，不眠布鲁克林。让我们从纽约市在这些新移民面前面临的最困难的事情开始——弄清楚把他们安置在哪里。很难找到合适的空间。一些社区真的不想要他们。
Shut it down! Shut it down!
关闭它！关闭它！
Send them back home!
把他们送回家！
Shut it down!
关闭它！
This is Staten Island, living up to every stereotype New Yorkers have about Staten Island when a migrant shelter got put there. There have also been protests in Brooklyn and Queens. With that in mind, the city opened up a new facility a month ago that the mayor said was chosen to be, quote, "the least intrusive as possible to current residents, while also being as humane as possible to migrants."
这是史泰登岛，当一个移民避难所设在那里时，它符合了纽约人对史泰登岛的所有刻板印象。布鲁克林和皇后区也有抗议活动。考虑到这一点，该市一个月前开放了一个新设施，市长说选择它是为了“尽可能减少对现有居民的干扰，同时尽可能人性化地对待移民。”
It is not in a building. It's four massive tents that, together, can house 2,000 people at a place called Floyd Bennett Field. One of our producers, Valerie Kipnis, visited right after it opened.
它不在建筑物里。它是四个巨大的帐篷，加起来可以安置2000人，地点叫弗洛伊德·贝内特机场。我们的制片人之一瓦莱丽·基普尼斯在它刚开放时去参观过。
When I first heard that Floyd Bennett Field was going to be the city's newest migrant center, it struck me, because I knew exactly where it was-- in the middle of nowhere. And I can say that with some degree of certainty, because I grew up in the same middle of nowhere-- or at least close by.
当我第一次听说弗洛伊德·贝内特机场要成为该市最新的移民中心时，我很震惊，因为我知道它在哪里——在荒郊野外。我可以相当肯定地说这一点，因为我就是在同一个荒郊野外长大的——或者至少离得很近。
It's called Floyd Bennett Field. But to me, it's always been the abandoned airport, slash place with the massive ice hockey rink, slash random chunk of land you pass just before Rockaway Beach. It's right on the water. There's not a lot of streetlights or ways to get there, unless you're in a car or on a bike.
它叫弗洛伊德·贝内特机场。但对我来说，它一直是一个废弃的机场，加上巨大的冰球场，再加上你在洛克威海滩前经过的那块随机土地。它就在水边。如果没有车或自行车，没有很多路灯或到达那里方式。
And if you're driving around at night, it feels like you're in the middle of the woods, not New York City. I wondered what it was like to get sent there as someone brand new to the city. So I went out with Jika Gonzalez. She's a reporter I've worked with before, who covers immigration.
如果你晚上开车四处走走，感觉就像在树林中间，而不是纽约市。我想知道作为一个刚到城市的人被送到那里是什么感觉。所以我去找了吉卡·冈萨雷斯。她是和我合作过的记者，专门报道移民问题。
We arrived at around dusk. There was the faint glow of cop cars near a massive encampment lit up by fluorescent lights. And there were the tents, surrounded by a giant metal fence and security guards.
我们在黄昏时分抵达。警车在荧光灯照亮的巨大营地附近发出微弱的光。那些帐篷被巨大的金属栅栏和保安包围着。
Jika and I arrived unannounced, hoping to talk to people hanging out around the shelter. But that night was actually so cold that there was basically no one outside, except for this one group of adults with some kids. The kids wore blankets over their heads, trailing on the ground behind them, cute, but cold, like little ghosts. And actually, they were on their way out, in a rush.
吉卡和我没打招呼就到了，希望能和在避难所附近闲逛的人交谈。但那天晚上实在太冷了，除了这一群带孩子的成年人，基本没人。孩子们头上盖着毯子，在地上拖着，可爱但寒冷，像小鬼魂。事实上，他们正急着要离开。
Hola, que tal?
你好，怎么样？
Why are you leaving here right now?
你们为什么现在要离开这里？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Nos estamos yendo de nuevo a la 45.
我们要回45号街去。
Trying to go to 45th Street.
试图去第45街。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
What's on 45th Street?
第45街有什么？
Qué hay en la
45?
酒店。对。
El hotel. Si.
罗斯福酒店，回到欢迎中心。小女孩名叫卡琳娜，但大家都叫她卡莉。她八岁，有大姐姐的气场，双马尾上跑出了几缕碎发。她说话时从脚后跟到脚趾摇摆。
The Roosevelt Hotel, back to the welcome center. The little girl's name is Karlina, but she goes by Karli. She's eight, has big-sister energy, pigtails that some wisps of hair have escaped from. She rocks back and forth from heel to toe as she talks.
她的家人几个小时前才到这儿。现在，他们要离开，因为这个地方不是他们想的那样。
Her family arrived here only a few hours ago. And now, they're leaving, because this place isn't what they thought it would be.
他们告诉我们说会把我们送到酒店，但这不是酒店。你看，这只是个帐篷，我们都睡在行军床上，所以我们也需要为孩子们提供隐私。你能理解吗？
Aqui nos habian dicho que nos
“他们说会把我们送到酒店，但这根本不是酒店。这是一个露营地，”其中一个男人说，“我们都睡在简易行军床上。我们需要给孩子们隐私。你明白吗？浴室也不在主帐篷里。你必须走到外面才能使用它们。”
iban a mandar para un hotel y no era un hotel. Mira es una--un acampamento donde estamos todos durmiendo en camillas pues, entonces nosotros también necesitamos una privacidad para los niños. Si me entiende?
在某个时候，他们开始担心公共交通。孩子们怎么从这里去上学？最近的火车站在4英里外。拉斐尔，卡琳娜的爸爸，想的是，我怎么从这里找工作？
"They said they were going to send us to a hotel, but it wasn't a hotel. It's a campsite," says one of the men, "where we're all sleeping on cots. And we need our privacy for the kids. You understand? And the bathrooms-- they're not in the main tent. You have to go outside to use them."
所以，我们寻找避难所是为了能开始工作。像你们美国人一样赚钱。
Sometime along the way, they began to wonder about public transportation. How are the kids going to get to school from here? The closest train station is over 4 miles away. Rafael, Karlina's dad, is like, how will I find work from here?
“这就是我们寻找避难所的原因，这样我们才能开始工作，像你们一样赚自己的钱。这样我们就可以租房子照顾我们的开销，你明白吗？他们告诉我们我们要去酒店，但当我们在路上时，突然意识到这就像个沙漠，一个孤岛。”
Entonces por una de esas cosas que nosotros buscamos refugio aquí para luego nosotros empezar a trabajar. Ganar nuestro dinero como ustedes también los Americanos.
市政府说它会给人看帐篷的照片和他们将要去的地方的地图。但我后来和这里的其他人谈过，我交谈过的人没人看过照片。许多人在抵达时很惊讶。
"That's why we're looking for shelter, so that way, we can start working, earning our own money, like you. That way, we can rent a house and take care of our expenses, you understand? They told us we were coming to a hotel, but then suddenly, when we were on the way here, we realized that this is like a desert, an island in the middle of nowhere."
卡琳娜、她爸爸拉斐尔和整个家庭，基本上，一到就开始想，我们不能住这儿。一定有别的地方。拉斐尔似乎很坚定。他想和给他们分配这里的人谈谈，也就是第45街罗斯福酒店的某个人。他们需要回去。
The city says it shows people photos of the tents and maps of where they'll be going. But I later talked to other people here, and no one I spoke to had been shown photos. Lots of them were surprised when they arrived.
这群人——原来有两个来自委内瑞拉首都加拉加斯的家庭。一位名叫丹妮拉的妈妈，她的丈夫拉斐尔，还有她的兄弟罗尼和他的家人，以及他们在路上遇到的另外两个人。想想他们走到这一步的旅程，让他们来到废弃机场大帐篷里的旅程。
Karlina, her dad, Rafael, and the whole family, basically, as soon as they arrived, started thinking, we can't stay here. There has to be something else. Rafael seemed determined. He wanted to talk to the person who assigned them here, someone at the Roosevelt Hotel on 45th Street. They needed to get back.
他们在夏末离开加拉加斯，花了三个月时间，经中美洲前往墨西哥，到彼德拉斯内格拉斯，然后进入得州。跨越边境后，他们有三个巴士选择——芝加哥、丹佛或纽约。他们认识纽约市的委内瑞拉人，对方说可以在这里得到帮助，孩子们可以上学，大人们可以找到工作。所以他们选择了纽约。
This group-- turns out there are two families from Venezuela, the capital, Caracas. A mom named Daniela, her husband Rafael, also her brother Roni and his family, and two other guys who they met along the way. Consider their journey up to this point, the one that got them to these giant tents in the middle of an abandoned airfield.
我们决定来这里，但结果他们在这里给我们弄了另一出。
They left Caracas in late summer, and for three months, made their way through Central America to Mexico, to Piedras Negras, and then into Texas. After they crossed, they were offered a choice of three buses-- Chicago, Denver, or New York. They knew Venezuelans in New York City who said they could get help here, that the kids could go to school, that the adults could find work. So they chose New York.
丹妮拉，卡莉的妈妈说，他们被告知会得到一个住处住两个月。“我们可以休息并寻找工作向前迈进，你明白吗？所以我们决定来纽约，因为这里能得到帮助。但这里完全是另一回事。这里太让人困惑了。”
Decidimos venirnos para acá, pero resulta que aquí ahora nos salieron con otra cosa.
你抵达市中心的罗斯福酒店，有温暖的大堂、早餐、行李寄存、避难所分配，在那几个月的混乱后有一刻宁静。然后，你被送上这辆巴士，它开始把你带离你一直想象的地方，带离所有的摩天大楼。
Daniela, Karli's mom, says they were told they'd get a place to live for two months. "We could rest and look for work to move forward, you understand? So we decided to come to New York, because we'd get help here. But here, it is something else. Here has been confusing."
突然，你到了这个别的地方，远离大中央车站的人群。然后，你下车，在一个看起来很像帐篷的地方被处理。因为那就是个帐篷。那是别的东西。
You arrive at the Roosevelt Hotel in the middle of the city, with a warm lobby, the breakfast, the bag check, the shelter assignment, the moment of stillness after months of chaos. And then, you get put on this bus, and it starts driving you away from the place you've been imagining, away from all the skyscrapers.
所以家庭决定离开，想方设法回到第45街。唯一的出路似乎是一个停车场里的城市巴士。前面滚动的霓虹灯牌写着“暂停服务”。附近有一个穿着公交管理局制服、拿着对讲机的男人，看起来被整个局面搞得很紧张。
And suddenly, you're in this other place, far away from the crowds of Grand Central. And then, you get off the bus, and you're processed in a place that looks very much like a tent. Because it is a tent. It is something else.
我这儿有15个人想上巴士，但他们都不会说英语。我搞不懂他们想去哪。我不能偏离路线，对吧？
So the family had decided to leave and somehow try to make it back to 45th Street. The only way out seemed to be a city bus in a kind of parking lot. The neon sign scrolling across its front read "not in service." There was a man nearby in a Transit Authority uniform with a walkie talkie who seemed stressed out by the whole situation.
当他说话时，他开始走向停着的巴士。所以这群人决定最好跟着他。他们几乎没行李，只有几袋塑料袋装着的东西。孩子们跑在前面。
I got, like, 15 people here that wants to get on the bus, but none of them speak English. I can't figure out where they want to go. I cannot go off route, right?
再见！再见！拜拜！
While he's talking, he starts walking towards the parked bus. So the group decides they better follow him. They have almost no belongings, just a few plastic bags of stuff. The kids run ahead.
孩子们爬上巴士，走到后面。有些人躺下。他们看起来筋疲力尽、昏昏欲睡。大人们完全不知道发生了什么，巴士要去哪。他们挤在巴士入口处。
Bye! Bye! Bye-bye! Ciao!
车上已经有另一个巴士司机了。拿着对讲机的巴士司机也上了车。他们都不会说西班牙语。给他们翻译的重任落在了吉卡身上。
The kids climb onto the bus, go to the back. Some of them lay down. They look exhausted, sleepy. The adults have no idea what's going on, where the bus is going or anything. They crowd near the entrance of the bus.
先生？抱歉，他们只是问我巴士带他们去哪儿。
There's another bus driver already on board. The bus driver with the walkie talkie gets on as well. Neither of them speak Spanish. It falls to Jika to translate for them.
发生了什么真的很不清楚。我后来得知，这是市政府设置的一辆新巴士，用来把人们从避难所送到地铁站。但在这一刻，在避难所运营的最初几天，司机似乎对要去哪里有点不确定。他开始翻找文件。
Sir? Sorry, they're just asking me where the bus is taking them.
是的，康尼岛。康尼岛不在曼哈顿市中心的第45街附近。它在相反方向。
It's really unclear what's happening. I later learned that this is a new bus the city set up to shuttle people from the shelter to a subway station. But at this moment, in the first days of the shelter's operation, the driver seems a bit unsure about where he's going. He starts looking through his paperwork.
所以去康尼岛坐火车。
Yes, Coney Island. Coney Island is not near 45th Street in the center of Manhattan. It's in the opposite direction.
所以你只是把他们带到火车站？
So it's going to Coney Island by the train.
对。
So you're only taking them to the train station?
如果他们想去——我想他们是想去第45街的罗斯福酒店。
Correct.
我不能偏离路线。
What if they want to go to the-- I think they're trying to go to the Roosevelt Hotel on 45th Street.
哦。
I can't go off route.
这是我的指令。
Oh.
我给他们翻译，行吗？你们现在在纽约的一部分。纽约叫布鲁克林。你们想去的地方是曼哈顿。那是两个不同的行政区。你可以理解为，这里叫“区”。
That's my instructions.
吉卡尽力用西班牙语向他们解释他的意思。她说，你们在纽约的一个地方叫布鲁克林，你们想去的地方是曼哈顿。那是两个不同的县。在这里叫区。
I'm going to translate for them, is that OK? Ustedes están en una parte de Nueva York. Nueva York se llama Brooklyn. Y donde ustedes quieren ir es en Manhattan. Son como dos condados diferentes. Haz de cuenta. Aquí se llaman boroughs.
他们问吉卡，我们怎么转车或付地铁费？我们刚到城市。我们没钱。家人一直要求去第45街，就像他们来时那样，司机一直重复说他不能偏离路线，只能把他们带到康尼岛，离他们想去的地方远着呢。
Jika's trying her best to explain to them in Spanish what he means. She's like, you're in a part of New York that is called Brooklyn, and where you're trying to go is Manhattan. It's two different counties. They're called boroughs here.
拿着对讲机的司机走出去，打了个电话，然后回来。说也许能在地铁站找个人帮助这家人。但这是一段很长的行程，坐巴士去康尼岛，然后坐地铁回第42街大概要一小时。
They ask Jika, how are we supposed to transfer or pay for a train? We just got to the city. We have no money. The family keeps asking to go to 45th Street, the same way they got here, and the driver keeps repeating he can't go off route, that he can only take them to Coney Island, nowhere near where they want to go.
他们对是否真的有人会帮助他们表示怀疑，因为他们觉得他们已经没怎么被帮助过，没人说西班牙语，而且非常困惑。（西班牙语）
The bus driver with the walkie talkie steps out, takes a call, and then comes back. Says maybe he could find someone at the subway station to help the family out. But it'll be a long trip, a bus ride to Coney Island, then, like, an hour on the subway back to 42nd Street.
骗人的，他们撒谎。他们把我们扔在那儿就走了。他们已经这么干过一次了。
They're just skeptical about if anybody's actually going to help them or not, because they feel like they were already not really helped, and that nobody speaks Spanish, and that it's very confusing. [SPEAKING SPANISH]
“他们把我们扔在那儿就走，”罗尼说。“他们已经那样对过我们了。”对讲机男又出去了，带回了一个解决方案。他在康尼岛找到了一个会说西班牙语的调度员。他会打开大门，让他们进去，并引导他们坐正确的火车。
Parece mentira, son mentiras de ellos. Ellos nos bajan ahi y siguen su camino. Eso ya nos lo hicieron ya.
他会说西班牙语，向他们展示怎么走。他告诉我很容易，直坐D线火车。就一趟车，没别的。
"They'll just drop us off there and go on with their day," Roni says. "They did that to us already." Walkie talkie dude goes out again and comes back with a solution. He's found a dispatcher at Coney Island who speaks Spanish. He's going to open the gate, let them in, and direct them to the right train.
他会宣布——他们会从那里坐火车，调度员会说西班牙语。所以他会把他们送上车。
He's going to speak Spanish to them and show them how to go. He told me it's easy, just D train straight. So just one train, that's it.
吉卡转过身翻译。你可以看到大人们开始放松一点。所以也许会成功？这看起来整个系统依赖于陌生人的善意，仿佛它靠巧合运作，而不是设计。巧合是这里有人能说西班牙语来翻译，巧合是巴士司机好心愿意在他们旅程的下一站找个说西班牙语的人。希望那个人能帮他们坐上回第42街的火车。希望在那个车站，有人能引导他们去酒店。对罗尼来说，这似乎要绕很大一个圈才能回到他们刚才的地方。
He's going to announce-- he's going to take the train from there, and the dispatcher speaks Spanish. So he's going to get them on.
就好像他们骗了我们，或者把我们送到一个像小木屋一样的地方？如果他们从一开始就说，你们要去某处，我们会从一开始就做决定。
Jika turns and translates. You can see the adults start to relax a little. So maybe it'll work out? It's as if the entire system relies on the kindness of strangers, as if it works by coincidence, not design, coincidence that someone here speaks Spanish to translate, coincidence that the bus driver is kind and willing to find a Spanish speaker at the next point in their journey. Hopefully, that guy can help them get on the train to 42nd Street. And hopefully, at that station, someone can direct them to the hotel. For Roni, it all seemed like a very long way to get back to where they had just been.
“他们把我们送到这里，某种露营地。如果他们一开始就说了，我们就不会决定来了。”吉卡问，“如果这是唯一选择呢？你们会待在这里吗？”
Como que dice nos mintieron o nos mandaron acá como con un cómo va un como con una cabaña? Si ellos no dicen desde un principio, van para un lado, nosotros tomamos la decisión desde allá mismo.
但如果这是唯一选择，你们会待在这里吗？
"They sent us here to some sort of camp. If they had said that from the beginning, we would not have decided to come." Jika asks, "What if this was the only option? Would you stay here?"
不。
Pero Si esta fuera la única opción, se quedarían aquí?
罗尼说，“不。”
No.
市政府发言人告诉我，你不能选择避难所。你被分配到一个。如果你不想待在那里，那你就得靠自己了。
Roni says, "No."
如果只有这里？或者街头？
A city spokesperson told me that you can't choose a shelter. You get one assigned. And if you don't want to stay there, then you're on your own.
杰西卡问，“如果这是这里或者街头呢？”
Si es esto? o la calle?
我们会想办法，也许四处走走，你会找到更多帮助。
Jessica asks, "And if it was this or the streets?"
“我们会搞定的。也许四处走走，我们会找到更多帮助。”
Ahí vemos como buscmaos de repente hay más ayuda por ahí ,caminando se encuentra más ayuda.
（西班牙语）
"We'd figure it out. Maybe walking around, we'll find help."
他在问，巴士几点离开？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
现在。
He's saying, at what time is the bus leaving here?
好的。
Right now.
告诉他们我会在回转处等。他会在那里等你们。我已经告诉他们了。他在找你们。好吗？谢谢。谢谢你，先生。
Yeah. OK.
就这样，他们走了。他们回到罗斯福酒店后我们发了一会儿短信，但后来就没消息了。我想也许他们换了新SIM卡。吉卡几天后去了那里但没找到他们。我又回弗洛伊德·贝内特机场看能不能找到他们，但没运气。
Tell them I'm going to be at the turnaround. He's going to be there waiting for you. I already told them. He's looking for you. OK? Thank you. Thank you, sir.
瓦莱丽·基普尼斯是我们节目的制片人。她是在吉卡·冈萨雷斯的帮助下报道的。
And with that, they left. We texted a bit when they got back to the Roosevelt, but then we stopped hearing from them. I think maybe they got a new SIM card. Jika went there a few days later but couldn't find them. I went back to Floyd Bennett Field to see if I could find them, but no luck.
第二幕，150天的苦日子。市政府对这些新移民的计划是，他们从避难所搬出来找地方住，这意味着赚钱付房租。难点就在这儿。
Valerie Kipnis is a producer on our show. She reported this with help from Jika Gonzalez.
大多数寻求庇护者刚抵达时不能合法工作，所以他们得想办法。我们的制片人戴安·吴，遇到了一位处境如此的人。
Act 2, 150 Days of Bummer. So the city's plan for all these new migrants is that they get out of the shelters and find their own places to live, which means making money so they can pay for that place to live. And there's the rub.
我在一个雨天的一家市政府办公室外遇到了沙克鲁德，当时他正在做最后一次尝试来获得避难所。他在等待里面的判决时抽烟休息。整个经历中很大一部分就是等待。我问了他一个我问每个人的那种随口一问。
Most asylum seekers can't work legally when they first arrive, so they have to figure something out. One of our producers, Diane Wu, met somebody in that situation.
你在纽约的第一天是什么样子的？
I met Shakrood outside a city office on a rainy day, while he was making a last attempt to get shelter. He was taking a smoke break while he waited for the verdict inside. So much of this whole experience is about waiting. I asked him a kind of throwaway question I was asking everyone.
就像惊喜。
What was your first day in New York like?
（笑）
It's like surprise.
就像——在我们国家，我们说“Subhanallah”。
[LAUGHS]
“Subhanallah”。这是阿拉伯语里的一个短语。我后来查了。它的意思类似于，“哇，赞美上帝，这是他创造的神奇事物。”
Like it's-- in our country, we say "Subhanallah."
这是一种宗教情感。
"Subhanallah." It's a phrase in Arabic. I looked it up later. It means something like, "Wow, praise God and this incredible thing he made."
就像一种神圣的见证感？
It's like a feeling for religion.
是的。
Like a sacred feeling to see?
沙克鲁德——顺便说一句，这不是他的真名。我们选择保护他的身份。他来自毛里塔尼亚。他23岁。他在那里是一名学生，学习银行保险——我也得查一下这个——和银行与保险有关。
Yeah.
沙克鲁德的第一语言是阿拉伯语。英语是他的第三语言。他今年7月开始学习它。7月——那是五个月前。你能相信吗？
Shakrood-- that's not his real name, by the way. We're choosing to protect his identity. He's from Mauritania. He's 23. He was a student there, studying bancassurance, which-- I had to look that up, too-- something to do with banks and insurance.
我在我们国家学习过。
Shakrood's first language is Arabic. English is his third. And he started learning it in July of this year. July-- that was five months ago. Can you believe that?
在学校里？
I studied in my country.
不，不。在手机上。
Like in school?
在手机上？
No, no. In my phone.
是的。
In your phone?
他发现了一个YouTube频道，基本上不间断地看了一周，然后找了个应用练习。他十几岁的妹妹取笑他，说这不是学习语言的方法。但显然，是的。
Yeah.
沙克鲁德是黑人。他离开毛里塔尼亚的部分原因是为了逃避那里的种族歧视。他8月下旬抵达纽约，被分配到第31街的一家避难所，因消防规范在10月关闭。市政府把他搬到一家新避难所，几周后也关闭了，这就是他今天为什么会在这个办公室申请新床位的原因。
He found a YouTube channel and watched it basically non-stop for a week, then found an app to practice on. His teenage sister teased him about it, that that was no way to learn a language. But apparently, it was.
他告诉我他已经睡在街上好几天了，晚上待在宾州车站附近一家开得很晚的非洲餐馆里，还有餐馆地下室的小清真寺里。沙克鲁德抽完烟进去看有没有床位——带着坏消息出来。
Shakrood is Black. And part of the reason he left Mauritania was to escape racial discrimination there. He arrived in New York in late August and was assigned to a shelter on 31st Street that got shut down in October because of the fire code. The city moved him to a new shelter, which also got shut down a few weeks later, which is how he ended up at this office today-- to apply for a new bed.
他们没能为我们找到任何地方。我们得走了。
He told me he'd been sleeping on the streets for a couple of days, spending the nights in an African restaurant near Penn Station that was open late, and in the tiny mosque in the restaurant's basement. Shakrood finishes his cigarette and goes inside to check if there's a bed for him or not-- comes out with bad news.
哦，你要去哪儿？
They couldn't find any place for us. We have to go.
回清真寺和餐馆。
Oh, where are you going to go?
他们给你理由了吗？
Back to the mosque and the restaurant.
他们说因为现在下雨，所有避难所都满了。避难所全满了。但我们不能抱怨，你知道。我们不能抱怨。
Did they give you a reason?
好吧。祝你好运。我稍后给你发短信，看看情况如何。好的。今天见到你很高兴。
They said it's because it's raining right now, and all shelter is full. The shelter all is full. But we can't complain, you know. We can't complain.
见到你也很高兴。
OK. Well, good luck. I'm going to text you later, see how it goes. OK. Nice to meet you today.
一周后我再次找到了沙克鲁德，听到我们初次见面一两天后他就找到了住处，我既惊讶又欣慰。他旧避难所附近一家烟草店友好的老板听说沙克鲁德在寒风中睡在街上，说想帮他。他有一个空置的空间，租给了沙克鲁德和他的两个朋友——不是真正的公寓，更像是个地下室——两室一卫，每月1600美元，每人500美元左右。
Nice to meet you, too.
他们新地方的第一晚——他们三个人非常兴奋终于有了自己的小窝，彻夜未眠，讨论怎么让它变得完美。他们决定买一套来自毛里塔尼亚的茶具。所有这些基本上都是市政府想要的——人们找到离开避难所进入世界的方法。
I found Shakrood again a week later, and I was surprised and relieved to hear that a day or two after we first met, he'd found a place to stay. The friendly owner of a smoke shop near his old shelter heard that Shakrood had been on the street in the cold and said he wanted to help him out. He had an empty space that he rented to Shakrood and two of his friends-- not a real apartment, more like a basement-- two rooms and a bathroom for $1,600 a month, around $500 a person.
但一旦你做到了，就得付房租。而沙克鲁德不能合法工作，因为他是寻求庇护者。寻求庇护者必须在申请庇护后等待150天，才能申请工作许可。这个特定的等待期是联邦政府在90年代发明出来的，旨在阻止人们利用庇护申请作为获得工作授权的方法。
Their first night in the new place-- the three of them had been so excited to finally have their own spot that they stayed up all night, talking about how to make it perfect. They decided to get a special tea set from Mauritania. All of this is basically what the city wants-- for people to find their way out of the shelters and out into the world.
你觉得那个系统怎么样？
But once you do that, there's rent to pay. And Shakrood can't legally work, because he's an asylum seeker. And asylum seekers have to wait 150 days after they file for asylum, before they can even apply for working permission. This specific waiting period was invented by the federal government in the '90s to discourage people from using asylum claims as a way to get work authorization.
嗯，没什么大不了的，因为每个国家都有要处理的事情——
What do you think of that system?
这些规定？
Yeah, it's, uh-- like-- it's-- there is no big deal, because they-- every country has stuff to do with--
是的。但是，150天——太长了。
These rules?
纽约市长和其他市长一直对着联邦政府大喊大叫，要求改变这一点。比如，如果你让他们进入国家却不让他们工作六个月，我们怎么能帮助这些人站稳脚跟。因为沙克鲁德不能合法找工作，他不得不找地下工作。
Yeah. But, like, 150 days-- it's a long time. Yeah, yeah.
他8月刚到时就开始了。他在纽约没有任何人脉，所以他的最初策略是这样。他有一天起床，开始进出商店和餐馆，询问工作，在整个城市里。
The mayor of New York, and other mayors, have been yelling at the federal government to change this. Like, we cannot help all these people get on their feet if you let them into the country but then don't let them work for six months. Because Shakrood can't get a job legally, he's had to look for one under the table.
我去皇后区、布鲁克林，某个地方——我甚至不知道它的名字。
He started right when he first got here in August. He didn't have any connections in New York, so his initial strategy was this. He just got up one day and started walking in and out of stores and restaurants, asking for work, all over the city.
也许是布朗克斯？
I go to the Queens, Brooklyn, someplace-- I don't know even its name.
对。是的。
Maybe the Bronx?
所以你会走路——你只是走进去，会说什么？会发生什么？
Yeah. Yeah.
我只是走进商店或大楼，打个招呼，像这样开始谈话。说，嘿，你好吗？问他们在找工作，我在找工作。有些人问，你喜欢什么样的工作？
So you would walk-- you just walk in and what would you say? What would happen?
我说，我没有特定的要求——什么都行，像洗碗工、理货员、收银员。什么我都能做。有些人说，不，我们现在不招人。有些人说写下名字和电话，他们会打电话。
I just go inside the store or the building and say, hi, make a conversation like this. Say, hi, How's it going? And ask him that I'm looking for work, I'm looking for a job. Some people ask, what kind of job you like?
好。
I say, I don't have a specific-- everything, like dishwasher, stocker, cashier. Everything, I can do it. Some people say, no, we are not hiring right now. Some people say to write my name-- my name and my number, and they will call me.
是的。我写下名字和电话就走。
OK.
每天花多少小时找工作？
Yeah. I write my name and my number and go. Yeah.
七小时，六小时。
And how many hours each day would you spend looking for jobs?
好。
Seven hours, six hours.
是的。
Yeah.
只是四处走走，进每家店说我在找工作？
是的。我想七——每天七、六个小时。
Just walking around, going into every shop and being like, I'm looking for work?
他去了太多地方，有时会不经意地回到同一家店。
Yeah. I think seven-- seven, six hours a day.
他们说，你之前问过我们了。是的，我说抱歉。很有趣。
He went to so many places, that sometimes he'd accidentally go back to the same one without realizing it.
有人回过电话吗？
They say, you asked us before. Yeah, I say sorry. Yeah, it's very funny.
没有，没有。没人。还没呢。（轻笑）
Did anybody ever call you back?
有一个金牌工作似乎不需要工作许可。但沙克鲁德不能做是有另一个原因。
No, no. Nobody. Not yet. [CHUCKLES]
我只找到一份工作，但它是——涉及酒精。
There was one golden job that didn't seem to require work permission. But there was another reason Shakrood couldn't do it.
涉及酒精。沙克鲁德走进一家酒吧，以为是餐厅，他们招聘人帮忙储备酒精。但沙克鲁德是穆斯林，对他来说，喝酒或接触酒精是禁止的。
I find only one work, but it's for-- with alcohol.
他告诉我他需要一个理货员。他试着让我做这个。他说他会支付4000美元。
With alcohol. Shakrood had wandered into a bar, thinking it was a restaurant, and they were hiring somebody to help stock the alcohol. But Shakrood's Muslim, and for him, it's forbidden to drink or work with alcohol.
4000美元？
And he tell me that he needs somebody to be a stocker. And he tried to make me to do this. He said he will pay $4,000.
一个月，是的。
$4,000?
一个月4000美元？
For a month, yeah.
是的。
$4,000 a month?
好。那你说了什么？
Yeah.
是的，我说这工资不错，但不适合我。
OK. And what did you say?
嗯。
Yeah, I said it's a good salary, but not for me.
是的，我不能做这个。他说，为什么？我说，因为我是穆斯林。他说，这没什么大不了的，因为也有穆斯林喝酒。我说，那不是我。
Mm-hmm.
那是你找到的唯一一份工作，结果你做不了？
Yeah, I cannot do this. He say, why? I said, because I'm Muslim. He said, yes, that is not a big deal there, because there is a people Muslim drinks. I said, not me. Yeah.
只有这一份。我找到了，但做不了。
That was the one job you found, and you couldn't do it?
沙克鲁德进行了20天左右这种折磨人且毫无收获的求职，然后放弃了。这是他在纽约最糟糕的时光，他告诉我——比没地方睡觉还糟糕。在那之后，他度过了一个月，基本上随波逐流，待在避难所，白天和朋友一起坐地铁，在随机站点下车。
It's only the job I have. I find it, but I couldn't do it.
他还有过短暂的约会尝试，他一边害羞一边自豪地跟我说了。有一天他在华盛顿广场公园遇到了一位女士。她是个美国人。
Shakrood ran this grueling and fruitless job hunt for around 20 days, then gave up. It was the worst part of his time in New York, he told me-- worse than having nowhere to sleep. After that, he had a month where he was just kind of adrift, staying in the shelter, spending his days riding the subway with a friend, getting off at random stops.
你们第一次互动是什么样？
He also had a brief diversion into dating, which he told me about kind of bashfully and proudly at the same time. He met a woman one day in Washington Square Park. She was an American.
就像站在那儿看人们跳舞。我说——（大笑）我想你很漂亮。能给个号码吗？
What was your first interaction?
那是你说的第一句话？你很漂亮，能给我个号码？
It was like standing and watching people, like, making dance. And I say-- (LAUGHING) you're beautiful, I think. Have you got a number?
是的。
That's what you-- that's the first thing you said to her? You're beautiful, can I get your number?
这管用？
Yeah.
没有，不完全是那样。她说她对我来说太老了，因为她28岁？
That worked?
她28岁？你23岁？好。
Yeah. No, it's not work like this. She said that she's so old for me, because it was 28 years?
她说，我太小了。我说是，这没关系。
She was 28? And you're 23? OK.
他陪她聊了10到15分钟，然后确实拿到了号码。他们约会了几次——一次在高线公园，一次在另一个公园，聊得很投机。
She said, I'm so young for her. Yeah, I said it doesn't matter.
她问我关于——告诉我关于我自己的事，工作。我住在哪里。我告诉了她。
He chatted her up for 10 or 15 minutes, and then did get her number. They went on a couple dates-- one at the High Line, another park, and talked a bunch.
他对她很坦诚。他告诉她他住在避难所，没工作。她笑了，说——
And she asked me about my-- to tell her about myself, my job. Where did I live. Yeah, and I tell her.
一边住在避难所一边找女孩约会这很有趣。
He was straight with her. He told her he lived in a shelter, didn't have a job. She laughed and said--
是的。
That's funny to looking for girls for relationships and you're living in a shelter.
她说那很有趣。
Yeah.
你说了什么？
She said that's funny. Yeah.
我说我不在乎。在那之后，我给她打电话。她没回。我知道那是为什么。
What did you say?
沙克鲁德告诉我他不觉得难过，也不在乎，只是删了号码。从那以后他没再试着约会任何人。在那之后，他问避难所里的人怎么去送外卖，这是纽约新移民的一种常见工作，你租一辆电动自行车或踏板车，每单赚几块钱。
I said I don't care. Yeah. Yeah, and after that, I call her. She didn't reply. I-- yeah.
难点是获得Uber Eats或DoorDash账号，因为开账号需要社会保障号码，沙克鲁德没有。但有一个庞大的账号地下市场。沙克鲁德有一天在第37街和百老汇的TD银行外遇到了一个账号经销商，花了150美元买了一个据称活跃两周的账号。用了两天就被踢出来了。
Uh-huh.
后来，一个朋友帮他找到了一个Uber Eats账号。那是他现在大部分时间在做的事，自10月中旬以来——骑着他租的绿色自行车穿梭在城里。
I know that's because what I tell her.
一天送多少单算好日子？
Shakrood told me he didn't feel sad or care much, just deleted her number. He hasn't tried to date anyone else since then. After that, he asked a guy in the shelter about how to get into doing food delivery, a really common job for new immigrants in New York, where you rent an e-bike or scooter and start making a few bucks per delivery.
20，23单。
The tricky thing about it is getting an Uber Eats or DoorDash account, because opening one requires a Social Security number, which Shakrood doesn't have. But there's a whole shadow market of accounts available. Shakrood met some kind of account dealer outside the TD Bank at 37th Street and Broadway one day, paid him $150 for an account that was supposed to be active for two weeks. He got kicked off after two days.
最好的日子，他赚过150美元。但我跟他说话那天，下午5点，整天只赚了19.75美元，离付房租差远了。
Later on, a friend helped him find an Uber Eats account. That's what he spends most days doing now, since mid-October-- riding his rented green bike around town.
所以你在工作许可下来前还有四五个月？未来四个月有什么计划？
How many deliveries will you-- would be a good day?
是的，我只是尝试生存。
20, 23.
尝试什么？
The best day he'd had, he'd made $150. But the day I talked to him, at 5 PM, he'd only made $19.75 all day, which doesn't get him much closer to making rent.
只是生存，保持生存，并保持有个地方——安全。就是这样。
So you have four months, five months before the work permit comes? What's your plan for the next four months?
安全。当我们11月下旬交谈时，沙克鲁德一直提起雪。他担心天气变坏后怎么骑车。这就是他现在想的，怎么挺过冬天，直到能拿到工作许可。还有128天。
Yeah, I just try to staying alive.
戴安·吴是我们节目的制片人。接下来——一段大型舞蹈解决了所有人的问题，就像电影里一样。来自芝加哥公共广播电台，一分钟后节目继续。
Try to what?
艾拉·格拉斯的《美国生活》。今天的节目——“远离关闭的车门”，这是纽约地铁上常说的一句话，也是市长对任何仍然想来纽约的寻求庇护者所传达的信息。今天我们有关于纽约市正试图安置和喂养如此多移民，且由市政府买单的前所未有的事情。我们已经到了节目的第三幕——第三幕，百老汇摇篮曲。
Just staying alive, to stay alive and to still have a place of like-- to be safe. Yeah. That's all.
几个月前当我们开始策划这一期节目时，我们注意到的一件事是，很多来到纽约的新移民在社交媒体上发布他们在时代广场的照片——比如，看，我们成功了。有时这些是在你看到他们浑身是泥、艰难地向北跋涉到美国后的帖子。
To be safe. When we talked in late November, Shakrood kept bringing up the snow. He's worried about biking once the weather gets bad. That's what's on his mind right now, how to survive the winter and make it till he can get that work permit. 128 more days.
如果你去时代广场看看，那里在游客、从郊区来看《狮子王》的家庭以及穿戏服的蜘蛛侠和埃尔莫中间，就是这些新来者。
Diane Wu is a producer on our show. Coming up-- a big dance number solves everybody's problems, just like in the movies. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
（西班牙语）
This American Life from Ira Glass. Today's program-- "Stand Clear of the Closing Doors," which is the thing that they say on the New York subway, and it also is kind of the mayor's message to any asylum seekers who still want to come to New York today. We have stories today about the unprecedented thing that New York City is trying to house and feed and settle so many immigrants all at once, with the city government picking up the tab. We have arrived at Act 3 of our show-- Act 3, Lullaby of Broadway.
这确实是我们刚来时到的第一个地方。我们——我们正好到了这里。
So when we started putting this episode of our show together a few months ago, one thing that we noticed was that so many new immigrants to New York on social media were posting pictures of themselves in Times Square-- like, look, we made it. Sometimes these were after posts where you would see them covered in mud, trudging their way north to the United States.
你们拍照了吗？
And if you go to Times Square and look around, there, in the middle of the tourists and the families who came in from the suburbs to see The Lion King and the costumed Spider-Man and Elmos, are these newcomers.
（西班牙语）
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
This was literally the first spot we came to when we got here. We got-- we arrived right here.
是的，当然，我们拍照了。
Did you take a picture?
肯尼和他的儿子内斯特一年前从委内瑞拉来到这里。现在，他们又回来了，在45街街角准备去麦当劳。他们有时会来时代广场，看看大屏幕，逛逛。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
离他们50英尺远，一个穿着灰色卫衣、带着哥伦比亚队徽章的家伙和他朋友坐在长椅上。他们有啤酒。穿卫衣的家伙，马特奥，已经在这里待了一年了，他告诉我们。但这并不是小组里所有人的情况。
（西班牙语）
Yeah, of course, we took pictures.
我们刚到这儿，因为我朋友刚到。
Kenny and his son, Nestor, got here from Venezuela a year ago, he said. Now, they were back, on the corner of 45th Street on the way into a McDonald's. They come to Times Square every now and then, look at the big screens, hang out.
（西班牙语）
Maybe 50 feet from them, a guy in a gray hoodie with a Colombian team logo on it was with his friends on a bench. They had beers. The guy in the hoodie, Mateo, has been here for a year, he told us. But that wasn't true for everybody in the group.
他才来了两天。他搬到了美国。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
We just came here right now, because one of my friends just got here.
所以我们从达里恩峡谷一路跋涉来到这里。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
花了四个月，他说。我问他是否会在时代广场拍照，他说，不了。
He's been here for only two days now. He moved here to the US.
（西班牙语）
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
我们没手机，因为我们在墨西哥被绑架了，被抢劫了。
So we've crossed all the way from the Darien Gap to come here.
在第46街，在词曲作者乔治·M·科汉雕像前，一对带着五个小孩子的委内瑞拉夫妇出来看灯，只是想把每个人都带出来。在第七大道，一位26岁的女孩坐在长椅上，这是她第三次来，她解释了吸引力。她喜欢看巨大的视频屏幕。它们很漂亮。
Took four months, he said. I asked if he was going to take a photo here in Times Square, and he said, nah.
（西班牙语）
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
我只是来，因为这里人多。车多，活动多。我通常独自在家，所以我想要分散注意，来这里看点别的。
We don't have any phones, because we actually got kidnapped in Mexico, and we got robbed.
你现在在打电话吗？
On 46th Street, in front of the statue of songwriter George M. Cohan, a Venezuelan couple with five little kids came out to look at the lights, to just get everybody out of the house. On 7th Avenue, a 26-year-old sitting on a bench was here for a third time, and she explained the appeal. She liked seeing the huge video screens. They're pretty.
（西班牙语）
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
其实我正在和朋友说话，给她看我在哪里，给她看时代广场。
I just come, because there's a lot of people. There's a lot of traffic, a lot of movement. I'm usually alone at home, so I want to distract myself and just come and see something else.
你的朋友在哪里？
You're on the phone right now?
她现在在智利。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
你是从哪里来的？
I was talking to a friend right now, actually, showing her where I'm at, showing her Times Square.
不，我是从秘鲁来的。
Where's your friend?
（西班牙语）
Ya esta Chile.
她很高兴，因为我正在过着我告诉过她的梦寐以求的生活，她很高兴我正在做这件事。
She's in Chile right now.
（西班牙语）
That's where you're from?
我的梦想是认识纽约，来到这里，对我来说进展相当顺利。所以我其实很高兴，感谢上帝。
No, yo soy de
（西班牙语）
I'm from Peru.
是的，这是时尚、大屏幕等等的国家。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
她在美国已经六个月了。她是和我谈过的那些旅程并不艰难或危险的人之一。她飞往墨西哥，步行穿过边境，被边境巡逻队带走并申请庇护。然后她从得州飞往纽约市。
She's happy, because I'm living the dream that I had spoken to her about for a long time, and she's very happy that I'm doing it right now.
她现在在布朗克斯和朋友住一套公寓。她习惯了地铁，不再迷路了。她在汉堡王工作，正在学习英语词汇和短语。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
“明天见。”（西班牙语）“再见，”或者“培根”、“泡菜”。（大笑）
My dream was to get to know New York, come here, and it's going pretty well for me. So I'm actually very happy, thank god.
靠在离她一个街区远的报刊亭旁，有个孩子我和我的翻译拉蒙完全搞不懂。16岁，厄瓜多尔人，待了四个月，和家人住一起，看起来还不错，父母都在工作。他说他在上高中，在一家叫Western Beef的超市有工作。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
但他说他每周三次来时代广场，每周都来，一待就是几小时。但无论如何，拉蒙和我完全无法理解为什么。当我们第一次走过去时，这个孩子——他的名字叫朱尼尔——正在看街头表演。
Yeah, this is the country of fashion and big screens and all of that.
（西班牙语）
She's been in the US for six months now. She was one of the people I talked to who did not have a difficult or dangerous journey here. She flew to Mexico, walked across the border, got picked up by border patrol and requested asylum. Then she flew from Texas to New York City.
我正在看表演。我看看人们如何展示他们的才华。
She's now sharing an apartment in the Bronx with a friend. She's gotten used to the subway, doesn't get lost anymore. She's working at a Burger King, picking up English words and phrases.
但你常来，每周都来。所以你通常做什么？
"See you tomorrow." [SPEAKING SPANISH] "See you later," or "bacon," "pickle." [LAUGHS]
（西班牙语）
Leaning on the side of a newsstand, maybe a block from her, was a kid who I and my interpreter, Ramon, could not figure out at all. 16 years old, Ecuadorian, had been here for four months, living with his family, who seemed to be doing OK, parents working. He said he was going to high school and had a job at a supermarket, called Western Beef.
But he said he would come to Times Square three times a week, every single week, stay for hours. But for the life of us, Ramon and I could not understand why. When we first walked up, this kid-- his name is Junior-- was watching some street performers.
四处走走看人们做他们的事，也许学点东西。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
告诉我你喜欢去这里的哪儿。
I'm just watching the show right now. I'm seeing how people can showcase their talents.
（西班牙语）
So you come a lot, though, every week. So what do you do, usually?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
这毫无意义。他有时喜欢坐在47街的红色看台上。你在这里见过人并和他们说话吗？不，他不说话。这是你纽约最喜欢的地方吗？不是。
朱尼尔，我们不太明白你为什么常回来。比如，我们明白你喜欢它，但我们不太明白为什么。多说点。为什么你来得这么频繁？
Just walking around and watching people do their thing, maybe learn something.
（西班牙语）
Tell me one of your favorite places to go here.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
我之前告诉过你。这就是原因。
说完，我们放弃了。拉蒙和我绕到朱尼尔靠着的报刊亭另一边，那里有个11岁的街头表演者，拿着一块写着他名字的字牌，奥斯卡。拉蒙注意到他写在字牌上的姓和朱尼尔的一样，问他是否独自一人。
This went nowhere. He likes to sit on the red bleachers sometimes on 47th. Do you meet people here and talk to them? No, he doesn't. Is this your favorite place in New York? Not really.
（西班牙语）
Junior, we don't totally understand why you come back so often. Like, we understand you like it, but we don't totally understand why. Say more about that. Why do you come so often?
不，我和我哥哥在一起。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
你哥哥是那边的朱尼尔吗？
（西班牙语）
What I had told you before. That's why.
是啊，是啊。
And with that, we threw in the towel. Ramon and I walked around to the other side of the newsstand that Junior was leaning on, where there was an 11-year-old street performer with a handwritten sign with his name, Oscar. Ramon noticed that his last name, which was written on the sign, was the same as Junior's, and asked him if he was here alone.
他来这儿是照顾你的吗？
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
（西班牙语）
Nah, I'm here with my brother.
Is your brother Junior over there?
当然，是啊。他是我哥哥。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
当我们回到朱尼尔身边时，他一直在看我们和奥斯卡谈话，他在笑，我猜，比如，啊，被抓到了。
Yeah, yeah,
（大笑）（西班牙语）
And he comes with you to take care of you?
是的，那是我哥哥，正在唱歌。（西班牙语）（笑）
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
他赚多少钱？
（西班牙语）
Of course, yeah. He's my brother.
When we returned to Junior, he'd been watching us talk to Oscar, and he was laughing, I guess, like, yeah, busted.
我想他一晚上大概赚150。
(LAUGHING) [SPEAKING SPANISH]
糟糕的晚上可能更像50。前天晚上，周六晚上，他赚了200。奥斯卡就是喜欢唱歌。从小在厄瓜多尔时就这样。
Yeah, that's my brother right there, singing. [SPEAKING SPANISH] [LAUGHS]
（西班牙语）
How much money does he make?
是的，这是我的激情。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
学校里的朋友知道你在时代广场唱歌吗？
（西班牙语）
I think I would say he makes around 150 a night.
Bad night would be more like 50. Night before this, Saturday night, he did 200. Oscar just loves singing. Ever since he was little, back in Ecuador.
知道，我告诉他们了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
他们怎么看？
Yeah, it's my passion.
（西班牙语）
Do your friends at school know that you sing in Times Square?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
哦，他们周一来看我了。
这是他的朋友马塞尔，来看他的。他和马塞尔读七年级。奥斯卡说他在厄瓜多尔本该读八年级，但当他来到纽约市，他们把他放进了七年级。这真是个遗憾。
Yeah, they know. I tell them.
无论如何，马塞尔和他的父母来了。奥斯卡说他们往盒子里放了10块钱。朱尼尔觉得，呃，他以为可能是1块或2块。奥斯卡正在存钱买手风琴。他最喜欢的歌手是马克·安东尼，所以我们要求唱一首马克·安东尼的歌。
And what do they think?
（西班牙语歌唱）
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
奥斯卡身穿他们在美国给他买的一件闪亮的新黑色冬装大声唱歌。看着他，我想到有多少歌手、音乐家和词曲作者走过这七八个街区，怀着在纽约成功的梦想。他一边唱歌一边盯着人群。人们投下钞票。
他真的似乎喜欢唱歌。就像我们很多搬到这个城市的人一样，在某个时候，你的梦想也会变成工作。这非常纽约。
Oh, they came to see me here on Monday.
第四幕，新孩子。
This was his friend, Marcel, who came to see him. He goes to seventh grade with Marcel. Oscar says he would have been an eighth grade in Ecuador, but when he got here to New York City, they put him in seventh. It was kind of a bummer.
学年开始时，纽约市学校里有2万名这样的新移民孩子。他们到了哪些学校有点随机。去年也是如此。
Anyway, Marcel came with his parents. Oscar says they put $10 in the box. Junior was like, eh, he thought maybe it was more $1 or $2. Oscar's saving up to buy an accordion. His favorite singer is Marc Anthony, so we asked for a Marc Anthony song.
我想我们从9月到12月没学生。然后突然是1月。就像，哦，你有这些学生了。
[SINGING IN SPANISH]
这是一所中学的学校辅导员。他要求我们不要命名。学校大约350名学生，规模偏小，相当多元。
Oscar belts out a song in a shiny new black winter coat they must have bought him here in America. And watching him, I think about how many singers and musicians and songwriters have walked down this exact seven or eight blocks with the dream of making it here in New York City. He keeps an eye on the crowd as he belts out his song. People drop dollar bills.
有一天，这位辅导员听说一些新移民孩子一直在哭并躲在厕所里。辅导员不会说西班牙语。孩子们不会说英语。
He really does seem to love singing. Like so many of us who moved to this city, at some point, your dream also turns into a job. That is very New York.
他们来到美国经历了这些创伤经历。他甚至无法和他们谈论。他觉得自己在辜负学生。
Act 4, The New Kids.
最后，就像今天节目里的很多人一样，他不得不自己临时拼凑些东西来处理问题。他找了两个学习辅导的西班牙语研究生，让他们顺便过来。他们给新学生做了几次辅导。
So there are 20,000 of these new migrant kids enrolled in New York City schools at the start of the school year. And which schools they arrived in was kind of random. That was true last year, too.
在这些辅导里，发生了一件令人惊讶的事。有些孩子确实想谈论他们的旅程。但那不是他们想讨论的大事。
I would say we went from like September to December with no students. And then all of a sudden it was January. It's like, oh, you're getting these students.
他们真正想谈论的是中学。有11岁、12岁、13岁的孩子。他们只是试图搞清楚任何中学生可能面临的问题。
This is a school counselor at a middle school. He asked that we not name it. The school is about 350 students, so on the small side, and pretty diverse.
所以我们的制片人之一阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德去了这所中学，花了一天时间跟孩子们谈论在纽约市上中学是什么感受。她和他们三个谈了谈。
And one day, this guidance counselor heard that some of the new migrant kids had been crying and hiding in the bathroom. And the counselor doesn't speak Spanish. The kids don't speak English.
我见到的第一个孩子叫塞琳妮丝。她在英语课上，大约20个孩子排排坐。塞琳妮丝是班里最小的，坐在后排，身板挺得笔直。她是那种全能的赫敏·格兰杰；非常有条理，喜欢知道老师问题的正确答案。
They had these traumatic experiences coming to the United States. And he couldn't even talk to them about it. He felt like he was failing his students.
她带着一点英语知识来到美国。但大多数移民学生根本不会说英语，所以他们不断在课堂上找塞琳妮丝帮忙，这让她感觉复杂。
In the end, like so many people on today's show, he just had to kind of jury-rigg something himself to deal with the problem. He found a couple of Spanish-speaking grad students who were studying counseling, and had them come by. And they did a handful of counseling sessions with the new students.
因为就像塞琳妮丝做这个。塞琳妮丝，帮帮我。我帮助所有朋友做家庭作业解释它们，因为我不喜欢这样，老实说。就像我说的，我是个负责任的人，不喜欢他们抄袭我的作业。我告诉他们至少用不同的话写，我不想要那样。有时我厌倦了，说别烦我了。
In these counseling sessions, a kind of surprising thing happened. Some kids, yeah, wanted to talk about their journeys. But that was not the big thing they were interested in discussing.
原因就是学校只有八个西班牙语成人来帮助翻译45个孩子，他们连日常英语都不会。所以很多孩子在课堂上一节又一节课却一头雾水，不知道发生了什么。学校确实有ENL课程（英语作为新语言），虽然老师不会说西班牙语。
The thing they really wanted to talk about was middle school. There are 11-year-olds, 12-year-olds, 13-year-olds. And they're just trying to figure out the same stuff any middle schooler might.
塞琳妮丝想和我谈论的是她的成绩。她为成绩压力很大。在厄瓜多尔，塞琳妮丝连续五年是全班第一。
So one of our producers, Aviva DeKornfeld went to this middle school to spend a day talking to kids about what it is like to settle in a New York City middle school. She talked to three of them.
在这里，她说她表现不错，除了人文学科和数学。人文学科很难，因为课堂上有太多谈话，全用英语。很难跟上。数学很难，因为词汇都很奇怪，比如老师会谈论分数。
The first kid I met was Celynnys. She was in an English language class, 1 of about 20 kids sitting in neat little rows. Celynnys is the tiniest one in class. She sits in the back row with front-row posture. She's a total Hermione Granger; very organized, loves knowing the right answer to a teacher's question.
所以我不知道，我说分数是一个词，是数学里的东西还是什么？她解释给我们听，我说你解释给我听的这些有什么用，我都不明白？
She came to the US knowing a little English already. But most of the other migrant students don't speak any English at all, so they're constantly asking Celynnys for help in class, which she has mixed feelings about.
很难知道老师说的词——这里是分数——是她还没学过的英语词，还是每个人都新学的词，即使是英语母语者。她担心老师没意识到，对于试图用外语学习的移民孩子来说，这到底有多难。
Porque es como Selene hace esto. Celynnys y me ayudas en esto. Yo ayudo en tareas a todas mis amigas las explico porque no me gusta, la verdad. Como les digo, soy una persona responsable, no me gusta que me copien la tarea. Yo les digo como haz diferente, aunque sea las palabras Y que no quiero hacer. A veces me harto y digo como ya déjenme en paz.
我和一位学校辅导员谈过这件事。他说老师们绝对意识到了并考虑到了这一点。他们计划用曲线评分，比平时更多地衡量参与度，这听起来短期内是一种善意，但不是真正的解决方案。
It's like, Celynnys, do this for me. Celynnys, help me with that. I helped them all with homework because I don't like them just copying my work. I tell them to at least write it differently. And sometimes, I just get fed up with helping and tell them to leave me alone.
导航中学成功与否与你在教室里学到的没多大关系。塞琳妮丝告诉我，关于做一名这里的中学生，她得弄清楚各种各样的规则。这里的规则多得多。
The reason all these kids keep asking Celynnys for help is because the school only has eight Spanish-speaking adults to help translate for 45 kids, none of whom speak even conversational English. So lots of kids just sit through class after class without a clue about what's going on. The school does have an ENL class, English as a New Language, though the teacher doesn't speak Spanish.
塞琳妮丝大概不出意外地是规则的支持者。但弄清楚什么是对是错，这是一个学习曲线。比如那天，她和朋友玩，但因为太粗鲁被送到留校。
The thing Celynnys wanted to talk to me about was her grades. She's stressed about them. Back in Ecuador, Celynnys was the top student, best in her class five years in a row.
但在我们中间我们从不伤害自己，因为我们总是这样玩，粗鲁，因为在那里我们了解那是游戏，是开玩笑，我们从不为那个吵架。
Here, she says she's doing pretty well except for in humanities and math. Humanities is hard because there's just so much talking in that class, all in English. It's hard to keep up. And math is difficult because the vocab is all weird, like the teacher will start talking about fractions.
她说她和朋友总是粗暴地玩，所以从不受伤。她们明白这是个游戏。我问她老师是否明白。
Pues yo no sé, digo qué fracción es una palabra, es algo de matemáticas o que es eso? Y ella nos explican y digo pero de qué me estás explicando si no entiendo?
是的，他们明白我们在玩，但说不管怎样我们都不该那样做。我问了一位认识塞琳妮丝的会西班牙语老师。她说校长给她看了女孩们的监控录像。很清楚她们是在玩，尽管她能看出为什么这会让校长感到担忧。
It's hard to know if the word the teacher is saying-- in this case, fraction-- is a word in English that she just doesn't know yet or if it's a new word for everyone, even the English speakers. She's worried the teachers don't realize how much harder it is for the migrant kids trying to learn in a foreign language.
我问塞琳妮丝她是否经常因为不懂规则而违反规则。她说，嗯，有时她很明白规则，但只是想玩像以前那样。
I talked to a school counselor about this. And he said the teachers definitely do realize that and take that into account. They're planning to grade the kids on a curve, weighing participation much more than they normally do, which sounds like a kindness in the short term, but not a real solution.
我谈的第二个女孩叫索菲亚。我的意思是，她跟我说话。她非常执着地跟我说话，因为她有很多想说的，“比如她喜欢科学课，因为老师有一只蜥蜴。”
So much of successfully navigating middle school has nothing to do with what you learn in a classroom. Celynnys told me that there are all kinds of things she's having to figure out about being a middle schooler here like rules. There are so many more rules here.
（西班牙语）
Celynnys, perhaps unsurprisingly, is a fan of rules. But figuring out what's considered right and wrong, that's been a bit of a learning curve. Like the other day, she was playing with her friend, but then got sent to detention for being too rough.
她想当演员或者兽医。
Pero en sí nunca nos lastimamos porque siempre jugamos así, brusco, porque allá estamos como ya entendido de que es un juego y que es bromeando y nunca nos peleamos por eso.
（西班牙语）
She says that she and her friends always play roughly, and so they never get hurt. They understand it's a game. I ask her if her teachers understood that.
她最喜欢的英语词是“水”（water）。她喜欢它的声音。
Sí, entienden que están jugando, pero dijeron que de igual manera no lo debíamos de hacer.
水。
They understand that we're playing, but said that we still shouldn't play that way. I asked one of the Spanish-speaking teachers who knows Celynnys well about this incident. She said the principal showed her the security footage of the girls. And it was clear to her that they were playing, though she could see why it would look alarming to the principal.
我想她在学校还行。很难说。她话题跳来跳去。一切都归类为我想分享的东西，包括从厄瓜多尔来美国有多难。
I asked Celynnys if she often found herself breaking rules simply because she didn't understand them. And she said, well, sometimes she understands the rules fine, but just wants to play like she used to.
首先，我们开始穿越丛林，我们在那儿没食物。我是说，我们两天没吃东西。
The second girl I talked to was Soffia. And by that I mean, she talked to me. She was very set on talking to me because she had a lot to say all at once, like how she liked science class because her teacher has a lizard.
索菲亚和家人两天没吃东西。在同一时间，她会告诉我她有多害怕家人被抢劫，以及纽约市看起来就像电影《金刚》里那样有多酷。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
其他孩子也这样。这是一种谈话时的怪异不协调，因为他们很兴奋地告诉你关于自己的事，但也经历了真实的苦难。所以他们争先恐后，同时试图用轻快的童声告诉我毁灭性的经历。他们只是想分享无论什么，重的或轻的，好像都有同等重量。
And how she wants to be an actress or maybe a veterinarian.
我谈的最后一个女孩叫玛丽安妮。我想见她是因为老师提到她在为女孩们编排一支舞。玛丽安妮笨手笨脚，走路像小长颈鹿，除了跳舞时，她经常跳舞。她告诉我，放学后，她喜欢听音乐，一边跳舞一边打扫房间。最近，一天下午，她有个想法。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
当我跳舞时我说：哎，我真的想跳舞，让每个人都看到我的舞。
And how her favorite word to say in English is water. She likes how it sounds.
我在跳舞。然后我就想，我要每个人都看我的舞。她决定在冬舞会上编排一些东西给女孩们表演。这看起来是个很好的社交机会。
Water.
她在和其他女孩为了糖果吵架后不久就有了这个想法。孩子们经常为食物吵架。就在前几天，图书馆员不得不在涉及一杯方便面的冲突中介入。
I think school is going OK for her. It was a little hard to tell. She pinballed from subject to subject. Everything just seemed to fall under the category of things I'd like to share, even how hard it was to come to the US from Ecuador.
玛丽安妮想做点什么来解决争吵。所以她想出了一个迪斯尼频道式的解决方案。让我们跳一支舞把每个人聚在一起。
Primero, empezamos a cruzar la selva y ahí nos quedamos sin comida. Osea, no comimos dos días.
她邀请其他女孩参加。近20个人想参与，这对玛丽安妮来说是个大事，因为她过去在委内瑞拉时非常讨厌学校。受到严重欺负。但在这里，在某种程度上，她发现交朋友更容易，因为所有移民孩子都困在一起。
Soffia and her family didn't eat for two days. In the same breath, she'll tell me about how scared she was that her family might get robbed, and also how cool it is that New York City looks just like it did in the movie King Kong.
今天是第一次排练。我们都下楼，玛丽安妮要教大家跳舞。房间是个带镜子和芭蕾杆的真实舞蹈室。
Other kids did this, too. It was this very weird dissonance talking to them because they're so excited to tell you about themselves, but they've also lived through real hardship. So they're clamoring over one another, all simultaneously trying to tell me about devastating experiences in these chirpy little voices. They just want to share whatever it is, heavy or light, like it all has equal weight.
你好，我们要跳舞了！
The last girl I talked to was named Marianny. I wanted to meet her because a teacher mentioned she was putting together a dance for all the girls. Marianny's gawky, carries herself like a baby giraffe, except for when she's dancing, which she's often doing. She tells me that after school, she likes to listen to music and dance while she cleans her room. And recently, one afternoon, she had an idea.
每个人都穿着袜子。玛丽安妮马上开始，带大家走过步骤。
Cuando estaba bailando yo digo: ay, pero es que tengo como unas ganas de bailar, que.. que todo el mundo vea mi baile.
（西班牙语）
I was dancing. And I was like, I want everyone to see my dance. She decided to choreograph something for the girls to perform during the winter dance. It seemed like a good bonding opportunity.
这支舞正是你想象中中学生女孩在卧室里编排的那样。看到孩子们在这种有空间容纳她们所有个性的环境下，这很不错。索菲亚跑来跑去，在墙上跳。塞琳妮丝，那个小赫敏，想知道动作的确切计数。而且因为她曾在厄瓜多尔上过芭蕾学院，有一些表演经验，坚持要作这个声明。
She'd come up with the idea shortly after a spat over some candy with some other girls. The kids often argue about food. Just the other day, the librarian had to intervene in an altercation involving a Cup-a-Noodles.
如果音乐停了，你们必须继续跳舞。
Marianny wanted to do something about all the fighting. So she came up with a solution straight out of Disney Channel. Let's make a dance to bring everyone together.
如果在表演过程中音乐因某种原因停了，继续跳就是。好建议，虽然有点早。她们几乎还没学好编舞。
She invited the rest of the girls to participate. Nearly 20 of them wanted in, which is a big deal for Marianny because she used to hate school back in Venezuela. Got bullied terribly. But here, in some ways, she finds it's easier to make friends because all the migrant kids are stuck together.
玛丽安妮，她真的很开心被包含在内，尽管整件事本来就是她的主意。关于如何跳舞有一些分歧。
Today is the first rehearsal. We all head downstairs where Marianny is going to teach everyone the dance. The room is a real dance studio with mirrors and a ballet bar.
就是这样！混蛋！
Hola, vamos a bailar!
但大部分时间，事情还好。在休息时，女孩们在地板上打滚、侧手翻、危险地挂在芭蕾杆上。几个玩着快节奏的转圈游戏。一个大女孩帮几个小的练习步骤。这简直是混乱，但好的那种。
Everyone's in their socks. Marianny gets right to it, walking them through the steps.
但笼罩在这一切之上的是，对纽约市很多移民家庭来说，截止日期临近了。市政府最近告诉家庭，他们只有60天的避难所时间。然后他们必须重新申请，有些人最早在1月第一周。新的避难所可能意味着完全不同的学校。女孩们现在感觉到的任何稳固性在新年时可能就没了。
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们的制片人。
The dance is exactly what you'd imagine a middle school girl might choreograph in her bedroom. It was nice to see the kids in this setting where there was room for all their personalities. Soffia is running around, bouncing off the walls. Celynnys, the little Hermione Granger, wanted to know the exact count of all the moves. And since she had gone to a ballet academy back in Ecuador and had some experience with performing, insisted on making this announcement.
第五幕，哈林舞曲。
Si la musica se para, tienen que seguir bailando.
所以一旦移民进入纽约提供的避难所，很多人根本不知道下一步该做什么或该跟谁谈。理论上，他们都有个案经理。但通常，他们不知道个案经理是谁。而且个案经理无论如何都被压垮了。
If during the performance the music stops for some reason, just keep dancing. Good advice, if a little premature. They've barely learned the choreography.
所以有各种各样的非营利组织试图填补缺口。其中之一由阿达玛·巴经营，也就是凌晨2点我在港务局迎接得州巴士时与我在一起的女士。再说一次，她的团体叫“Afrikana”。伊曼纽尔·佐齐顺道去看看他们能分担多少市政府的压力，以及他们在哪里挣扎。他在这儿。
Marianny, for her part, honestly just seemed happy to be included, even though this whole thing was her idea in the first place. There were some disagreements about how to do the dance.
Afrikana在哈林区145街和莱诺克斯的一栋不起眼的建筑里。大部分窗户被封上了。没有标志。我确信我来对地方的唯一原因是当我早上10点到时，门口有一长队人，绕着大楼排进停车场。
Si es! Caracho!
里面有个小等候区，一张坐着三个人的长桌负责接收，还有一连串临时隔间。看起来基本像个微小、混乱的车管所，那种如果你站得太久，某人就会把你拉进他们需要帮忙处理的随机任务的地方。可能是翻译、复印文件，或者，像我一样，帮某人抱一会儿幼儿。
But mostly, things went fine. And during breaks, the girls rolled around on the floor, did cartwheels, precariously hung off the ballet bar. A few played a high-speed game of ring around the rosy. One of the older girls helped a few of the younger ones practice the steps. It was total chaos, the good kind.
你好。你想替我工作吗？
But hanging over all of this is the fact that for a lot of migrant families in New York City, there's a deadline approaching. The city recently told families that they only have shelter for 60 days. Then they'll have to reapply, some as soon as the first week of January. A new shelter could mean a new school entirely. Whatever solidness the girls feel now might be gone by the new year.
（婴儿咿呀声）
Aviva DeKornfeld is a producer on our show.
监督一切的是阿达玛·巴。七个月前，在她多年来开着车帮助移民和寻求庇护者后，她创办了这个地方。太多人需要她的服务，她需要一个办公室。现在，她说每天有大约500人。
Act 5, Harlem Shuffle.
我们没宣传这个地址，因为客流量太大。
So once migrants get into the shelters that New York is providing, lots of them have no idea what they're supposed to do next or who to talk to. In theory, they all have case managers. But often, they have no idea who those case managers are. And the case managers are overwhelmed, anyway, with lots of cases.
人们怎么知道来这儿？
So there are all kinds of nonprofits trying to fill the gaps. One of them is run by Adama Bah, the woman who I was with till 2:00 in the morning at the Port Authority greeting a bus from Texas. Again, her group is called Afrikana. Emmanuel Dzotsi dropped by there to see how much of the city's slack they're able to take up and where they're struggling. Here he is.
口碑。
Afrikana is in a nondescript building in Harlem at 145th and Lenox. Most of the windows are boarded up. There's no signage. The only reason I knew I was in the right place was because when I pulled up at 10:00 AM, there was a long line of people that trailed out the front door, around the building, and into a parking lot.
纯粹吗？
Inside, there's a small waiting area, a long table with three people doing intake, a series of makeshift cubicles. It looks basically like a tiny, chaotic DMV, the sort of place where if you stand around for too long, someone will pull you into a random task that they need help with. It could be translating, copying papers, or, in my case, holding someone's toddler for a second.
口碑。
Hi. You want to do my job for me?
她创办这个地方是为了服务像几内亚和毛里塔尼亚这样的一代新移民，他们在过去几年一直前往美国。那些人从这个夏天开始大量涌入，部分原因是尼加拉瓜政府决定改变签证制度。所以非洲人可以直接飞到尼加拉瓜，从那里走路和搭便车到美国。你不再需要经过连接哥伦比亚和巴拿马通常致命的达里恩峡谷。社交媒体上传开了消息。于是很多人来了。
[BABY JABBERING]
如果你环顾房间，你会发现大多是黑人移民，对吧？这是一个他们能得到看起来像他们的人提供直接服务的地方。无论去哪，他们都被拒绝。没人会超越职责去翻译，如果他们不会说那语言。但这里每个人都会说那种语言。
Overseeing everything is Adama Bah. She started this place seven months ago after years of helping immigrants and asylum seekers out of her car. So many people needed her services, she needed an office. Now, she says they get roughly 500 people a day.
像普拉尔语和沃洛夫语，还有阿拉伯语和法语。每个提供这些服务的人都是志愿者，包括阿达玛。她做这些没工资。
We don't advertise this location because of the volume that we get.
为了赚钱，她有一份兼职。看起来她勉强应付过来，这很疯狂，因为我在Afrikana的大部分时间里，我发现自己在想，如果这个地方不存在会发生什么？
So how do people know to come here?
我看着一个人又一个人进来询问转发到Afrikana的重要邮件，因为随着他们不断在避难所之间搬家，这是他们永久的通信地址。我遇到了一个一周前刚生完孩子、拖着腿在办公室走动、缝着针的女人，因为她只想和自己国家的人待在一起。在这种情况下，我看到阿达玛在板条箱里翻找邮件，平息争吵。
Word of mouth.
她在桌上开个快速Zoom会议似乎都办不到，因为前几天受过帮助的人跑过来给她更新情况或需要更多指导。我一直盯着她，我是说，不停地弄丢手机，因为她把手机给了那些早就学到如果需要避难所经理、律师或任何有用的人，如果他们觉得阿达玛·巴在打电话，处理速度会快得多的人。
Purely?
试图跟上她，我一直寻找不引人注目的方式告诉她我真的需要一分钟喘口气。但她说没休息，尤其是在她帮助所有人时。
Word of mouth.
我有个随机问题问你，很简单。你什么时候喜欢——你吃什么？
She founded this place to serve a new generation of migrants from places like Guinea and Mauritania who've been making their way to the United States in the last couple of years. Those people started coming in large numbers this summer in part because of a Nicaraguan government's decision to change their visa system. So Africans could just fly to Nicaragua, and from there, walk and hitchhike to the United States. You no longer had to pass through the often-lethal Darien Gap connecting Colombia and Panama. Word spread on social media about it. And lots of people came.
他解释说来自几内亚。说双亲都去世了。几年前在该国发生军事政变后，他生活中唯一的父母角色，一个或多或少收养了他的军官，失踪了。
If you notice when you look around the room, it's mostly Black migrants, right? It is the one place where they get people that look like them that are giving them direct services. Everywhere they go, we're turned away. There's no one who's going above and beyond to translate if they don't speak the language. But everyone here speaks that language.
（法语）
Languages like Pulaar and Wolof, but also Arabic and French. And everybody providing those services is a volunteer, including Adama. She's not getting paid for any of this.
这让我震惊。我不知道他是在监狱还是死了。我不知道。我不知道。所有这些促使我离开那个国家，因为在那里，我的生活没保障。
To make money, she has a part-time job. And it seems like she's just about making all of this work, which is wild because most of her time I was at Afrikana, I found myself thinking, what would happen if this place didn't exist?
幸运的是，拉明说他认识的人帮他逃了出来，我想补充一下，这对拉明来说总是这样。他就是有那种寻找合适的人帮忙的本领。他身上有种真诚，我想，赢得了他们的心。
I watched person after person come in to inquire about an important piece of mail they had forwarded to Afrikana, because with all of the moving they were doing from shelter to shelter, this was their permanent mailing address. I met a woman who'd had a baby just a week earlier who was limping around the office, stitches and all, because she just wanted to be around other people from her country. And in the middle of this, I saw Adama digging through crates looking for mail, calming disputes.
他就是这样从街上的随机陌生人那里找到了在纽约的第一个避难所。这也是他听说Afrikana的方式。拉明给我看了他的Facebook页面。那是他在得州机场的一段视频。
She seemed unable to get through a quick Zoom call at her desk without someone who'd been helped days earlier popping by to give her an update or needing more guidance. I watched her constantly, and I mean, constantly lose track of her phone because she'd given it to volunteers who'd learned long ago that if you need something from a shelter manager or an attorney or anyone useful, it'll happen just that much faster if they think Adama Bah is calling.
（法语）
Trying to keep up with her, I kept looking for discrete ways to tell her that I could really use a minute to catch my breath. But there are no breaks, she says, not when she's helping all of these people.
这算得上他来到美国的成功视频。他看起来羞涩，几乎尴尬。但他非常快乐。
I have a random question for you, which is a simple one. When do you like-- when do you eat?
他看起来确实真的很年轻，不知为何比我面前的拉明还年轻。三周时间差异真大。既然到了纽约，他真的不怎么跟家里人谈。他感到内疚。
I'm eating now. I have a peppermint. I don't eat because they're not eating. So I'm so embarrassed to eat in front of them. So I'd rather chew gum and a peppermint.
（法语）
You wait until you get home?
我把WhatsApp里的非洲号码删了。我换了美国号码，这样我就能忘记。
Unfortunately, yeah. I'm surprised I'm not skinny. [LAUGHING] Follow me. Next spot.
拉明不想想起在几内亚的生活。但他也不想谈论纽约。
Adama's biggest challenge today is 27 young men, aged 18 through 21 here in the US without their parents. Today, Adama wants to find them all housing. And she's trying to get them into what she says is the gold standard here.
（法语）
Instead of regular migrant shelters, she wants to get them placed in the city's youth shelter system. That system serves all young New Yorkers aged 16 through 21 without homes, not just migrants. And in the youth shelter system, you could potentially get a spot for up to two years, not just 30 days. You also get vocational training, mental health services, and help finding schools, which are all services these kids would rarely get in the regular migrant shelters.
我觉得人们会问我他们怎么来这儿。他们会觉得能改变生活，一切都会变。但恰恰相反。如果不是处于极大危险中，我不能告诉国家里的人来这里。
It's going to be hard for Adama to place all 27 boys, though, because a lot of the youth shelters are full. Most of the boys know that they could be in for a bit of a wait, so they spread out around the room lounging. Almost everyone is on their phones watching soccer and talking to people back home.
如果你有危险，行，因为这里美国有保障。但这里，无证生存不容易。不容易。
One guy, though, who isn't on his phone is a 19-year-old named Lamine. He's the one person who asks me straight up, who are you exactly? Do you work with immigration?
（法语）
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
现在，他待在避难所里，曼哈顿旁兰德尔岛上的大型帐篷设施。但再过两周，他将面临该市30天的期限。这也是他为什么会在Afrikana的原因。他在想下一步去哪。
No, no, [SPEAKING FRENCH]
随着白天过去，27名年轻男性越来越不安。到目前为止，阿达玛只为这些人中的两个找到了叫“盟约之家”的避难所。她说这是城里最好的避难所之一。
I speak French because I lived in Belgium for a few years as a kid. Never picked up the word for podcast, though. And as I struggle to remember if I can just say podcast, I can feel Lamine sizing me up, wondering if I can be helpful to him in any way. He figures out quickly that I probably can't. But he's still happy to talk with me.
一直等到7:30，差不多在我到达Afrikana 10小时后，一直帮阿达玛忙一整天的志愿者之一回信了她一直在等的地方。这个组织会接收孩子。但她告诉男孩们，有个条件。
He explains that he's from Guinea. Says both of his parents are dead. And a couple of years ago after a coup d'etat in his country, the one parental figure in his life, a military officer who'd more or less adopted him, went missing.
（法语）
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
只有16个人能去，她说。她念了16个名字。拉明不在名单上。他看起来很沮丧。他得明早回来，把这一切重做一遍。我告诉他我稍后会赶上他。我跟着16个孩子走出门。
It shocked me. I don't know if he was just in prison or if he's dead. I don't know. I don't know. All of it pushed me to leave the country because back there, my life wasn't guaranteed.
那些年轻人还有最后一项任务要完成。他们得走30分钟路才能到住处。好，我们走。我开始陪他们走，才发现有几个掉队的。
Luckily, Lamine says he knew someone who knew someone who could help get him out, which, I should add, always seems to be a thing for Lamine. He just has this knack for seeking out the right people for help. And there's an earnestness about him, I think, that wins them over.
他们来了。嘿，嘿，我们要走了。
That's how he found his first shelter in New York from a random stranger on the street. And it's how he heard about Afrikana. Lamine showed me his Facebook page. There's this video of him at the airport in Texas.
然后我才意识到。我和这些年轻人都有地址。但我有谷歌地图。我不是跟着这些年轻人去他们的下一个居住地。我是送他们过去。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
有点混乱。几个 चार्ज走在前面，动得好像他们知道去哪，即使他们并不懂，行为甚至有点无礼，好像没跟我在一起。我看着其中一个试图乱穿马路，差点一头扎进迎面而来的车流。
It's kind of his I've made it to America video. He looks sheepish, almost embarrassed in it. But he is so incredibly happy.
等等，等等，等等，等等。如果你死了一个，我就完了。
He looks legitimately really young, younger somehow than the Lamine in front of me. What a difference three weeks makes. Now that he's in New York, he doesn't really talk to people back home. And he feels guilty about that.
令人惊奇的是，我们安全准时到了目的地。我按响那里的门铃。然后其中一个少年，就是我刚才从交通中拽回来的那个，拍了拍我的肩膀问我，你会和我们一起等，对吧？看到没？
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
我不会离开你们。（大笑）
I got rid of my African number on WhatsApp. I got an American number so I could forget.
我看到了。
Lamine doesn't want to think about his life in Guinea. But he doesn't want to talk about New York, either.
我有你。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
I think people will ask me how they can get here. They'll think they can change their lives, that everything will change. But it's the opposite. I can't tell someone in my country to come here if you're not in big danger.
我有你，兄弟。
If you're in danger, OK, because here in the US there is security. But here, being undocumented is not easy. It's not easy.
然后一个女人打开门欢迎我们。嗨。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
嗨，你们。
Right now, he's in a shelter, a big tent facility on Randall's Island next to Manhattan. But in just two weeks, he'll run up against the city's 30-day limit. That's actually why he's here at Afrikana. He's trying to figure out where to go next.
我只是送他们过来的记者。
As the day goes on, the 27 young men are getting restless. So far, Adama has only managed to find places for just two of these guys at a shelter called Covenant House. She says it's one of the best in the city.
她有重要信息要分享给每个人，但她不会说法语。所以我翻译。
It's not until 7:30, almost 10 hours after I arrived at Afrikana, that one of the volunteers who's been helping out Adama all day hears back from a place she's been waiting on. This organization will take kids. But she tells the boys, there's a catch.
我只欢迎他们待五天。周一早上，他们回Afrikana。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
五天，就是这样。我告诉男孩们这些，感觉真糟糕。这不会是他们的新家。每天，他们必须从早上8点到晚上8点离开这儿。
Only 16 people can go, she says. She reads out 16 names. Lamine is not on that list. He looks upset. He's going to have to come back in the morning and try all of this all over again. I tell him I'll catch up with him later. And I follow the 16 kids out the door.
其中一个男孩对着我嘟囔，（法语），真疯狂。我不知道该说什么。我有点同意。
Those young men have one last task sitting between them and this day finally being over. They have to make a roughly 30-minute walk to where they'll be staying. All right, let's go. I start walking with them, only to realize that we have a couple of stragglers.
我以为我去Afrikana是去看城市安全网下面的安全网，一个接收所有那些城市可能没接住的人的地方。但那个安全网有洞。尽管阿达玛和志愿者付出了所有努力，但感觉这一切都归结于运气。
They are coming. Hey, hey, hey, we leave.
在随后的几周里，我收到了一些男孩的短信和电话。他们告诉我他们没被安置在长期的青年设施中，而是转为待在城市普通的移民避难所。
And then it dawns on me. Me and these youth were both given the address. But I'm the one with Google Maps pulled up. I'm not following these youth to their next living situation. I'm taking them there.
阿达玛告诉我以前安置年轻人更容易。我恰好在10月下旬去那儿，就在它开始变得几乎不可能的时候。青年避难所系统满了。
It's a little chaotic. A few of them charge ahead, moving like they know where they're going even though they don't, and acting kind of insultingly like they're not with me. I watch one of them try to jaywalk and almost go headfirst into oncoming traffic.
几周来，我没听到拉明的消息。但当我联系上他时，他告诉我他待在“盟约之家”，阿达玛说最好的大型青年避难所。他说他是从那天在Afrikana遇到的一个人那儿拿到的地址，然后自己去了。我进来了，他告诉我。
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. wait. If one of you dies, I'm so fucked.
（法语）
Amazingly, we get to our destination in one piece and on time. I ring the doorbell of the place. And one of the teenagers, the same one I yanked back from traffic earlier, taps me on the shoulder and asks me, you're going to wait with us, right? See how it is?
每天早上6点，我起床去盟约之家问有没有位置。他们告诉没位置，所以我回来了。第二天，他们说仍然没位置，但也许如果我再去，可能有个名额。所以我日复一日地去。然后他们告诉我有个名额。
I won't leave you guys. [LAUGHING]
（法语）
I see you.
我成功了。没靠Afrikana帮助。我独自完成的。就我。
I got you.
（法语）
你能听出来吧，声音里的骄傲？他应该骄傲。
I got you, bro.
他没进盟约之家两年的项目。但他们给了他60天的位置。他去上学，慢慢学英语。他仍在试探我怎么能有帮助，我想。最近我们交谈时，他问了我几个关于我自己的移民故事，我怎么来的。
And then a woman opens the door and welcomes us. Hi.
阿达玛告诉我也许有很多拉明这样的人，自己找到方法。这是她最初开Afrikana时的目标。她帮人们，他们就会离开，因为她把他们连接到了合适的人那里。但她每天服务数百人，因为很多人最后又回来了。更多的人不断涌入。
Hi, you guys.
我从Afrikana回家的那个晚上，在一起待了10小时后，我在床上大概一个小时就接到阿达玛的电话。有几辆巴士在路上，她今晚要迎接。又要重新开始这一切。
I'm just a journalist who walked with them over from the thing.
（音乐演奏）
She has some important information to share with everyone, but she doesn't speak French. So I translate.
伊曼纽尔·佐齐制作了今天节目的这一集。
I'm going to welcome them for five days. Monday morning, they go back to Afrikana.
（“纽约，纽约”）
Five days, that's it. I feel terrible communicating this to the boys. This is not going to be their new home. And every day, they have to clear out of here from 8:00 AM to 8:00 PM.
（唱歌）开始传播这个消息。我今天就要离开。我想成为它的一部分，纽约，纽约。
One of her boys mouths to me, [SPEAKING FRENCH], it's crazy. I don't know what to tell him. I kind of agree.
制作今天节目的人包括Bim Adewunmi、Chris Benderev、James Bennett the Second、Phia Bennin、Jendayi Bonds、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Andrea Lopez Cruzado、Chana Joffe-Walt、Tobin Low、Miki Meek、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Ike Sriskandarajah、Lilly Sullivan、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala、Marisa Robertson-Textor、Matt Tierney和Julie Whitaker。我们的执行编辑是Sarah Abdurrahman。资深编辑是David Kestenbaum。执行编辑是Emanuele Berry。
I thought that when I went to Afrikana, I'd be taking a look at a sort of safety net under the city's safety net, a place that was catching all these people the city maybe wasn't. But that safety net has holes in it. For all the work Adama and her volunteers put in, it feels like it all comes down to luck.
我们今天有Gwynne Hogan的编辑帮助。我们最早通过Eliana Perozo的一篇Chalkbeat文章得知阿达玛·巴和Afrikana。
In the weeks that followed, I got texts and calls from a couple of the boys. They told me that they hadn't gotten placed in a long-term youth facility, that instead, they doubled down on staying in the city's regular migrant shelters.
我们今天有许多翻译。沃洛夫语翻译Arame Ngom。普拉尔语和法语Abou Dia。Charlotte Morlie也做了法语翻译。阿拉伯语Hany Hawasly，他也帮我们核对事实。西班牙语翻译David Mora，他也帮我们做了现场制作、Andrew Belisle、JoAnn DeLuna以及我在时代广场的翻译Ramon Mendez。第五幕的英语配音Karim Diane。
Adama told me it used to be easier to place young people. I happened to be there in late October, right when it started to become almost impossible. The youth shelter system is full.
特别感谢Jamie Powlovich、Michelle Navarro、Jasmine Garsd、Jordan Salama、Bahar Ostadan、Cody-Rae Knue、Camille Mackler、Rachel Lissy、Kirstyn Brendlen、Kate Smart、Gabriella Munoz de Zubiria、Natalia Vellejo Ulloa、Eric Chen和Dana Ballout。
For weeks, I didn't hear anything from Lamine. But when I did get in touch with him, he told me he's staying at Covenant House, the big youth shelter Adama says is one of the best. He says he got the address off someone he met that day at Afrikana, and he took it from there. I got in here myself, he told me.
我们的网站thisamericanlife.org，你可以免费在线收听我们超过800集的存档。《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交换中心）传送到公共广播电台。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人Torey Malatia先生，他听说《纽约客》要发行一千页的假日版杂志时感到震惊。想象一下，想象一下门口的集体重量。
Every day at 6:00 AM, I got up to go to Covenant House to ask if they have a place. They told me there is no place, so I came back. The next day, they said they still didn't have a place, but that maybe if I came back there, it might be a spot. So I kept going day after day. And then they told me they had a spot.
这个问题会摧毁纽约市。
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。
I did it. Not with the help of Afrikana. I did it alone. Just me.
（“纽约，纽约”）
[SPEAKING FRENCH]
（唱歌）如果我能在那里成功，我在哪里都能成功。纽约。这取决于你，纽约。
You can hear it, right, the pride in his voice? And he should be proud.
你听到了吗，他声音里的自豪感？他确实应该感到自豪。
He didn't get into one of Covenant House's two-year programs. But they did give him a spot for 60 days. He's going to school, learning English slowly. He's still sussing out how I can be useful, I think. Lately when we've talked, he's had a few questions for me about my own immigration story, how I came here.
他没能进入誓约之家（Covenant House）的两年期项目，但他们给了他一个为期60天的名额。他正在上学，在慢慢地学习英语。我想他还在琢磨我能怎样帮到他。最近我们交谈时，他问了我几个关于我自己的移民经历的问题，问我是怎么来到这里的。
Adama told me she has a lot of Lamines, people who figure it out on their own. That was her goal when she first opened Afrikana. She'd help folks, and they'd be gone because she'd have connected them to the right people. But she's serving hundreds of people a day because so many of them end up returning. And so many more keep arriving.
阿达玛告诉我，她有很多像拉明那样的人，都是靠自己解决问题的人。这正是她当初创办Afrikana时的目标。她会为人们提供帮助，而他们最终会离开，因为她已经为他们对接了合适的人选。但她现在每天要接待数百人，因为其中许多人最终又回到了这里。而且还有更多的人不断涌入。
The night I came home from Afrikana after 10 hours with her, I'd been in bed about an hour when I got a call from Adama. There are buses on the way that she was meeting that night. Starting the whole thing all over again.
在那天和她待了10个小时从Afrikana回家后，我上床躺了一个小时左右，就接到了Adama的电话。她当晚要去接几辆正在路上的大巴。一切又要从头开始了。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放中]
Emmanuel Dzotsi produced today's episode of our show.
本期节目由Emmanuel Dzotsi制作。
["NEW YORK, NEW YORK"]
["纽约，纽约"]
(SINGING) Start spreading the news. I'm leaving today. I want to be a part of it, New York, New York.
（歌唱）开始传播这个消息吧。我今天要离开了。我想成为它的一部分，纽约，纽约。
People who put together today's show include Bim Adewunmi, Chris Benderev, James Bennett the Second, Phia Bennin, Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Andrea Lopez Cruzado, Chana Joffe-Walt, Tobin Low, Miki Meek, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Ike Sriskandarajah, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天节目制作团队的成员包括 Bim Adewunmi、Chris Benderev、James Bennett the Second、Phia Bennin、Jendayi Bonds、Sean Cole、Michael Comite、Andrea Lopez Cruzado、Chana Joffe-Walt、Tobin Low、Miki Meek、Stowe Nelson、Katherine Rae Mondo、Nadia Reiman、Ryan Rumery、Ike Sriskandarajah、Lilly Sullivan、Frances Swanson、Christopher Swetala、Marisa Robertson-Textor、Matt Tierney 和 Julie Whitaker。我们的执行主编是 Sarah Abdurrahman。我们的高级编辑是 David Kestenbaum。我们的执行编辑是 Emanuele Berry。
We had editing help today from Gwynne Hogan. We first heard about Adama Bah and Afrikana from a Chalkbeat article by Eliana Perozo.
今天我们得到了 Gwynne Hogan 的编辑帮助。我们最初是通过 Eliana Perozo 在《Chalkbeat》上发表的一篇文章了解到 Adama Bah 和 Afrikana 的。
We had many interpreters today. Wolof interpretation by Arame Ngom. Pulaar and French by Abou Dia. Charlotte Morlie also did French. Arabic, Hany Hawasly, who also helped us with fact checking. Spanish interpretation by David Mora, who also helped with field producing, Andrew Belisle, JoAnn DeLuna, and my interpreter in Times Square Ramon Mendez. Voiceovers in English in Act 5 from Karim Diane.
我们今天有许多口译员。沃洛夫语口译由 Arame Ngom 担任。普拉尔语和法语由 Abou Dia 担任。Charlotte Morlie 也负责了法语部分。阿拉伯语由 Hany Hawasly 担任，他还协助我们进行了事实核查。西班牙语口译由 David Mora 担任，他还协助了现场制作，此外还有 Andrew Belisle、JoAnn DeLuna 以及我在时代广场的口译员 Ramon Mendez。第 5 幕的英语旁白由 Karim Diane 配音。
Special thanks today to Jamie Powlovich, Michelle Navarro, Jasmine Garsd, Jordan Salama, Bahar Ostadan, Cody-Rae Knue, Camille Mackler, Rachel Lissy, Kirstyn Brendlen, Kate Smart, Gabriella Munoz de Zubiria, Natalia Vellejo Ulloa, Eric Chen, and Dana Ballout.
特别感谢今天的Jamie Powlovich、Michelle Navarro、Jasmine Garsd、Jordan Salama、Bahar Ostadan、Cody-Rae Knue、Camille Mackler、Rachel Lissy、Kirstyn Brendlen、Kate Smart、Gabriella Munoz de Zubiria、Natalia Vellejo Ulloa、Eric Chen以及Dana Ballout。
Our website thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，您可以在那里免费收听我们八百多期节目的存档。This American Life 由公共广播交易平台 PRX 发行至各大公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder Mr. Torey Malatia, who was horrified to learn that the New Yorker is coming out with a thousand-page holiday edition of the magazine. Imagine, imagine the collective weight on the front stoop.
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他得知《纽约客》要出一本一千页的假日版杂志时感到非常震惊。想象一下，想象一下放在前廊上的总重量。
This issue will destroy New York City.
这个问题将会摧毁纽约市。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周同一时间，带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
["NEW YORK, NEW YORK"]
["纽约，纽约"]
(SINGING) If I can make it there, I'll make it anywhere. New York. It's up to you, New York.
（歌唱）如果我能在那里成功，我就能在任何地方成功。纽约。纽约，一切取决于你。